this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
talking we're talking about American
Idol right now which is a subject I know
you're very matched
did you say your full name
so my full name is actually Ade Remy
adeleke
Adair
case that is as Nigerian oh yeah that's
pretty well in the states they just call
you Remy in the street they call me Remy
states in the streets bro there's a
specific meaning behind it so at Day
means crown and Yoruba and and and Remy
means has appeased me and then adelake
means the crown has is supreme because
my grandfather was a royal Chief in the
uh in the Europa tribe
you're talking about Nigeria one of the
most populous countries I think the most
populous country in Africa yeah yeah
more English speakers in Nigeria I
believe than Colorado anywhere in the
world practically yeah a lot of people
don't realize that they're more English
speakers in Nigeria than there are in I
believe the United Kingdom how about
that dude at home for you the all of the
United Kingdom that is correct sir they
are an incredibly populous country yeah
are we sure about that or not that's not
that's not right
the English language right that is
correct but I'm just take a look but you
know Nigeria was a British colony for a
long periods that's true and uh sore
spot but it's true yeah
so
16 million speakers so 60 million so
type in how many English speakers in the
United Kingdom
[Music]
the UK
let's do it yeah a little bit but the
point is okay three or six minutes
okay
uh well that says United States
Pakistan has more 104 million how about
that the United Kingdom is 68 million so
only about 8 million more yeah how about
that yeah interesting a lot of people
don't realize that you got to put
Nigeria you got to give Nigeria it's
Prof yeah you do but you said don't
touch the UK right which is stupid what
do you mean 60 68 that's pretty close
you never would have thought it was a
lot of people no I agree it's close you
should have said it's close but when you
when you said so confident that's why I
said that's why I went I think I'm right
Canada I've been doing the show so long
with them I know what he's lying well
you know what I'm a little too common
[__] yeah but confident though no full
of [__] right I was close but your your
story starts and your story is so insane
so for the fans are listening Dr Drew
recommended you yeah yeah we get people
that recommend their friends whatever
all the time okay dude and they sent us
your name I was like let me look in them
like holy yeah no [__] you wrote a book
no [__] they're doing movies how they
don't do a movie on your entire life
stories and it works already
you know in Nigeria grew up basically
royalty yeah yeah yeah you're talking
royalty Chief in the Europa tribe and
then and then uh pops gets assassinated
is that fair to say assassinated let's
get killed they had taken out yeah it's
oh so my story really starts with my
grandfather's story my grandfather he
had nine wives and he was a chief in the
Europa tribe so
um you know in in eastern and western a
lot of Western culture we refer to
royalty as king queen prince princess
Dutch that sort of thing an African in
Africa and a lot of of Nigeria and
western Africa specifically royalties
referred to as Chief so when you have
that title that's that's almost
equivalent to a king oh wow and so my
grandfather had that title um he was one
of many chiefs in the Yoruba Tribe that
therefore he had like eight wives and
his goal in life was to produce an heir
to the throne which was a male and so he
had nine wives and he kept on having
daughters damn near the wives and then
finally my dad came along and my dad was
was the firstborn son so he got the
title of Chief and uh he had obviously
the last name but at eight years old my
grandfather died and when he died all of
the wives pretty much disseminated and
went their separate ways and so my
grandma my father my grandmother brought
my father down to the south of Nigeria
specifically Legos and there at the time
they were Christian Christian
missionaries and not only were they
teach in the Bible but they were
teaching science and math and literature
and just all the different topics that
we learned in school and my dad was a
savant he was super brilliant I mean he
had memorized the Quran by the time he
was six because my grandfather was
Muslim and so he was able to memorize
mathematical equations in history and
science and all of these different
things to the point where he ended up
getting a full ride scholarship to study
engineering and architecture in London
and that's when he took on the name John
because his name is actually his name
was adebayo which is my brother's first
name but because of to pay back the
missionaries he said all right I'm going
to adopt the name John so he put John in
front of adebayo moved to the UK and uh
study architecture engineering got his
bachelor's got his Masters and then he
started accumulating his wealth in in
the west and he became he was like the
first black man on the border the
British financial planning Council in
Great Britain he was one of the first
black men on Board of the World Trade
Center here in the United States the
dude was like he was a master of
business architecture correct me if I'm
wrong real quick when it comes to the
Nigerian culture yeah it's very common
to see like like uh I don't know like a
Nigerian who doesn't have four degrees
is rare oh yeah yeah well his education
[__] not back then though
if you have a bachelor's that's like a
GED
that's right you're just beginning yeah
my brother has a masters in in
engineering electrical engineering I
have a master's I have my my sister has
a masters I have another half brother
who's a doctor it's required it's
required oh yeah if you look at the
Nigerian uh so so people talk about
racism in this country if you look at
the Nigerian uh immigration experience
very similar to anybody you know who's
white as an immigration
they got all the degrees doctors there's
also dominated UFC yeah
[Music]
it's like it's like you know a lot of
Nigerians they believe that the Nigeria
is the cradle of civilization and that's
why the Nigerian people are so
intelligent they might be real and do so
well in other countries you know
Nigerians are the most successful
immigrants in America when you look at
everything across the board from
education to business to to working in
sectors like health and stuff not to get
on your dick too much there's a there's
a book called The Sports Gene and uh he
does very very it makes a very good
argument for the fastest people in the
world yeah or from a very tiny part of
Africa basically it'd be off for Coast
yeah basically not sprinters yeah of the
long distance no sir well Jamaica would
be so so so Jamaica come the people that
came from Jamaica came from from the
camera Ghana and Nigeria during the
Civil War
well if he did it like a 23andMe or
ancestor you would probably find some
Nigeria you would find all the
cornerbacks in the NFL come from West
African ancestry typically that area of
Africa sir so uh again please continue
yeah there's a white cornerback there's
one there is one what if he is he's like
actually actually I wouldn't be
surprised but go on but so yeah you'll
see your dad accumulates all this well
yeah yeah and then he came to the
realization he was like Hey Nigeria can
and should be like the West yeah because
of the natural resources Nigeria is like
one of the most wealthiest countries not
just in Africa but in in that entire
region and some of the smart people
infrastructure Tech as well so we got
oil just look at the natural resources
alone you got oil got natural gas you
got cocoa you got gold you've got so
many other resources that come out of
Nigeria and go to different places and
so my dad was like in if I could somehow
take everything that I've learned in the
west and go back to Nigeria I can build
it to be as on par if not better than
Western Nations like America that was
his vision he was he was a very far
thing far thinking man he always saw he
always saw 10 20 30 steps ahead it's a
good way to get killed yeah yeah and uh
and create enemies and so my dad went
ended up going back to Nigeria starting
his businesses he started his
Architecture Firm now was successful and
are you around at this time or no this
is like this is like the early 70s this
is the early seven this is before he
even met my mom and um and he bought
this massive plot of land in Nigeria
called Marico it's like m-a-r-a-k-o
something to that effect and it was like
a slum and his goal was to kind of
completely transform Miracle into like a
Wall Street and so what happened was in
the 1970s I can't remember the exact
date there was a military coup he paid 8
million pounds for that land so it had
adjust for inflation and everything
that's going on now that's that's like
equivalent to like 100 million dollars
especially when you're looking to go
from pounds to dollars and so
um the uh there was a military coup and
the Nigerian government the military
conference again they took everything I
mean they were killing politicians it
was like nuts and so my dad wasn't going
to fight that he couldn't fight that
he's just one man so essentially once
democracy was reinstalled he went back
through the courts in order to get his
land back because it was taken from
military people from the from the
government because the because the
because the military handed it back over
to the government handed everything
power and everything back over to the
government and uh essentially the court
said okay we see that you paid for this
what do you want you know we're not
going to give you back Miracle do you
want your money back and so my dad said
I want there was a swamp this disgusting
swamp it was a lagoon but it was
essentially a swamp he's like I want the
swamp and he said he laughed at me it's
like the swamp what do you want to swamp
for he's like I just want the swamp
because what he was thinking was he was
going to hide he was going to hire um
Dutch Engineers which he ended up doing
to dredge the foreshore to develop what
was a swamp into a man-made Island oh
well and so in his mind he said if I
create something what a vision where
there was never something no one could
ever come back and confiscate it or say
it was mine he was trying to you know
protect his assets and uh so they said
okay they laughed and they gave him the
swamp and uh
fast forward a couple years later you
know he started doing the development
but that's when he met my mom my mom is
from New York so my mom grew up in
Harlem she's a New Yorker she was a
flight attendant traveled all over the
world and then she loved art she always
loved music she loved African art as
well and so uh it was like 1980 1981.
she used to fly into Lagos she flew all
over the world Legos all over Europe
everywhere but she lived in New York she
was based out of New York and then um uh
there was a Yoruba Art Exhibit at the
Metropolitan Museum of Natural History
one day and so my mom was like I don't
know if I want to go but you know I'll
go I'll go check it out because it's the
last day and my dad happened to be in
New York because he was doing business
at the World Trade Center and so he he's
being him being Yoruba he was like all
right I'm gonna go to the net to check
out this Yoruba exhibit to see how legit
it is so he goes to the Met he meets my
mom they they're staying staring at a
piece of art at the same time my dad had
the Suave British accent you know yeah
he was a Suave cat and uh you start
stalking her and my wife my mom's a New
Yorker though so my mom was like get
away from me like what are you talking
about get away from me so then they they
went there separate ways and they ended
up meeting at another piece of art see
my mom thinks it was an accident but my
dad my looking back in retrospect my
mom's like nah he was he was fine this
is crazy
I'm sorry that's my crap
yeah did I mention I'm a chief yeah yeah
yeah that's kind of how it happened to
my mom was like yeah whatever he's like
yeah I'm a Euro Patron is that and my
mom was like okay so anyway they end up
going on a date and then um they got
married five months later damn yeah and
uh uh they got married in November which
I didn't find this out until years after
I married my wife but they got married
on the same day I married my wife and
you had no idea and I had no idea until
after I married my wife me my wife had
an anniversary and she was like my mom
one day she's like you know that's what
they mean your dad damn that's cool
that's crazy yeah so uh they got married
and my mom moved to Nigeria with my dad
and my mom was like exposed it was like
I tell people all the time my mom and
dad story is the real Coming to America
yeah
yeah like the real deal yeah is I
remember fast forward a little bit just
sorry to jump ahead I remember being on
a ship in the Navy and I'm standing I'm
standing in line waiting to go get ciao
and in the military you have on you know
your name tag your last name and your
rank and all that and I'm standing there
just waiting in these two black dudes
walk past me and just like it coming to
America when uh Eddie was at the
basketball game and the two players
walked past and they had on their
coveralls and they stopped and one of
them came back and he said I do lick it
you know I had to lick it he started
going to you I had that liquor and he
starts just rattling off in Europe
speaking you're about damn idiot both of
them
and I'm like ah man I'm sorry I don't
know what you said I do not speak your
tongue
and he's like you I had to let you need
to know your tongue you need to speak
and they start going off and then they
and then they left so going back that
was the life that my mom was kind of
thrust into she gets to Nigeria
everybody's referring to my father as
Chief or Your Excellence and she's from
the bra she's from she's from Harlem
Harlem she's from Harlem you know so
this is a new world where she my dad
didn't live in the house he lived on a
compound he had drivers he hadn't we had
nannies he had Cooks he traveled all
over the world I mean my dad was he was
legit he was a very rich woman guy he's
a chief and so that's when my brother
came along in 1981 he was born and then
a year later I was born in 1982 so that
was a life I was I was born into I was
born into a life of opulence like it was
well I bet it was fun everything I got
pictures I got pictures in my office now
me on horses with our driver who who
corralled and took care of our horses
and Us in France and my mom and my
grandmother has on fur coats and my
dad's there and it's like you know top
hat and coat and all that so yeah the
life the life was legit we went to a
private school we went to a really
really private school that I actually
got to go visit a couple years ago when
I finished writing my book and got to it
was like one of the top private schools
in like not just in Nigeria but in
Africa a lot of people who did business
from Europe they sent their kids if they
lived in in Nigeria they sent their kids
to this particular school so that was
was that was a life that I was
essentially born into let's take a break
can we take a break dude I'm not taking
a break from the road because I'm in La
Jolla comedy store first week of June
June The Comedy Store La Jolla right
outside San Diego June 2nd through the
4th that's two shows Friday two shows
Saturday one show Sunday and I'm jumping
across the pond the Europe tour starts
in Belfast June 15th one show only in
every city the theater tour so the thick
uh Europe tour starts June 15th in
Belfast Glasgow June 17th Rochester June
18th London June 22nd Cardiff June 23rd
then I end the Europe trip in Dublin at
the Vicar Street theater June 25th get
your tickets on thickboy.com this
weekend this weekend Friday Saturday and
Sunday Philadelphia Helium Comedy Club
Memorial Day Weekend come on out uh we
got some we got some funny and I got
Comedy Works at the end of the month
June 29 June 30 July 1. it's gonna be
great
this man good money habits start with
your very first paycheck if you just
scored your first job you've got an
opportunity to jump start a healthy
Financial Journey you don't want to get
behind right sign up for chime guys oh
my God qualifying direct deposit you get
access to benefits like being paid
getting paid up to two days early and
fee free overdraft up to 200 and with
chime there are no monthly fees no
minimum balance and no deposit required
to become a member how about that wow so
sign up for chime checking account today
link your paycheck it only takes two
minutes doesn't affect your credit score
get started at chime.com fighter that's
chime.com fighter and chime is a
financial technology company not a bank
banking services and debt card provided
by The Bancorp Bank n a or stride Bank n
a how about that members FDIC of course
so you're federally insured Early Access
direct deposit funds depends on payer
spot me eligibility requirements and
overdraft limits apply seechime.com spot
me how about that
I just gave our guests some houses
Steel Slash Hollywood Superstar Remy
some Macadamia chocolate dipped neck
from House of back a day those are my
go-to dude it is the talk around the
water cooler here at thick boy Studios
everyone wants our nuts eat them every
single day eat them every single day
dude people are coming for our nuts and
when I have people over we put them in a
little bowl and it's a very high class
snack oh dude I feel super people are
like I'm sorry are you a billionaire I'm
like yes my billionaire will be all my
friends you know I have billions only
all my friends are that's right let's
come over they come over and they go
they go this reminds me of home because
they eat no you're making good
Investments that's what they say they
will no it's House of macadamia because
they work with 96 South African Farmers
to make these nuts more accessible
products too it's no added sugar or
artificial ingredients hand sorted nuts
they none the head sort the nuts with
hands I'll sort your nuts with my hands
they got uh they got dipped in chocolate
Daddy they got uh the nut bars that are
on the creamy Nut Butter nut but I just
put my two fingers in it oh man you did
didn't you the chocolate yeah I did no I
legit put my fingers so good
um dude and then we have a great offer
for you guys for this month only their
best-selling product through and through
is their nebian
namibians sea salted Macadamia so we
thought for a limited time instead of
extra virgin Macadamia Oil they're gonna
offer the fire kid listeners and viewers
a free box of those delicious sea salted
macadamia nuts worth 35 bucks began for
free all right with your first purchase
when you go to House of macadamias.com
tfak you get 20 off the whole order with
the code tfak plus you get the sea
salted macadamia nuts
get you some nuts get some nuts how long
were you there yeah then pops uh gets uh
murdered at some point yeah so in 1987
um there was a lot of things that
transpired between 82 and 87 but in
short after the land had finally formed
around 86 87 it finally formed into what
was called the Lagoon development
project and my dad had invested millions
of millions of more dollars into it he
had signed contracts with with
businesses to have businesses and
companies on the island because again it
was supposed to be like a Wall Street I
think he had signed contracts with
McDonald's as my memory surgeon right
and other companies as well and uh he
would invest so much money that my mom
would she would plead with him she would
say you know bio like can you at least
put some money back in the States
because I don't trust the system and all
of our assets included in the house all
of our art my dad was an avid art
collector I went to an art gallery when
I was in Nigeria a couple years ago uh
it was called like the Nikkei art
gallery and to this day she's she's kept
some of my dad's art in her gallery and
so all of that was wrapped wrapped up in
the island my mom would tell them if the
Nigerian government does what they did
before we're going to have nothing
correct and my dad would say my
loyalties to my people damn let me get
this off the ground get people paying me
rent get the businesses going on the
island and then we'll put all the money
in the U.S and and and get his lawyer
his loyalty was essentially his downfall
fast forward after the land had fully
formed it was a fully formed Island
um The Lego state government came in
because this was in Lego State proper
the Lego state government came in and
said that the Legos that the Nigerian
federal government was never supposed to
award him the swamp this is why this is
but this is the story in every [__]
country yeah Africa Middle East yeah all
over and and when you don't have
property rights yeah the strength of
this country yes West is that you have
courts that mean something and that deed
means yes and the reason that you don't
have Entre entrepreneurial people like
who are entrepreneurs like your dad who
create wealth reasons you don't have the
creation of wealth yeah in Russia as
well yeah Eastern Europe is because a
strong man or corrupt government
officials with guns behind them come in
and can take everything you work for so
you have a business you work for 30
years very cool we're gonna come in and
take it and that's why all the best
people in Nigeria like everybody yeah
that is the curse of the Middle East
yeah
the government's killing it yeah they're
killing all the dreams and hopes the
buildings Mexico same thing without
property rights without without deeds
and credit cards meaning something all
that matters is cash and and might makes
right so so they take the so much today
my dad go support yeah so my dad goes to
court fights them in the process he dies
he dies three weeks later so he
essentially an autopsy he was poisoned
essentially yep so he went to me so he
he got bit by a dog
um he went to the hospital and my dad
when he was super stressed out he would
just go for walks around around outside
and around our neighbor we lived on
Victoria Island which is like the
Beverly Hills of of Nigeria and he went
for a walk and a dog you know neighbors
dog ran out bit him and uh my dad did
that walk many a times never got bit by
a dog knew the dogs knew the neighbor
knew the dog never happened
um he goes to the hospital there's a lot
more to the story I explained in all of
my book but he goes to the hospital he
gets medication and it was it was
essentially poison so they so they
essentially poisoned him and killed him
because my dad had my dad had so much
power even outside of his business he
was connected to the generals General
Dungey yeah which is a very famous
General some may say a very corrupt
General was my dad's best friend oh damn
the oluwoyu who's like considered the
the king supreme leader of the Yoruba
was my dad's best friend my dad would
bail a lot of these people out so we
have connections even though the state
the government to be a general in that
military yeah
so then once they basically poisoned
your dad take him out you guys lose
everything we lose everything because at
that point who's gonna fight them yeah
my dad has no allies my mom is American
and she wasn't really accepted you know
he wasn't really ex you know she wasn't
really accepted as an American a lot of
people don't realize that but in some
African countries like African-Americans
are like looked down a point didn't I
say that one time like Africans like
Nigerians look at American blacks yes
and they're like you're not marrying I'm
sorry you're not married 100 like
there's a lot of racism
took a he he ran look at that
[__] he ran he ran Nigeria he
was a in a coup yeah he was not a good
guy he's just always crying uh well
that's scary
Nobel prize winning poet a Nigerian poet
put to death for writing a poem
basically that was critical of them yeah
and uh the International Community tried
to get involved but he was a bad dude
man yeah that's the nature of the game
over there oh in order to get to the top
to get to the top like that you got to
be ain't happy so my dad's head of
security our head of security to this
day
he's the manager of the island which is
now considered a change the name from
Lagoon development it's now Banana
Island so if you look up Banana Island
like the richest Nigerian on the planet
has a freaking has a a house Compound on
Banana Island they did that from a swamp
DeVito yeah
that's your pop that's my dad so it's
still a success
they took it they took his idea they
took it and they turned it it was It was
supposed to be a business sector it was
supposed to be a Wall Street but now
it's a um
now it's a residential for the upper
class for the for the uh for the uh for
the rich that was my dad one of the
first
uh nah nah I think that's a that's like
a lagoon that's where they didn't so
people could go with swimming oh gotcha
yeah yeah so yeah that was it and I went
there and like I said the guy who was my
dad's head of security except which
means that my dad's had a security
played a role must have played a role in
some in some way with what happened
tomorrow yeah it's like you get this
done yeah here you go he's a manager
there's a history of poisoning too among
leaders it's really weird bummer way to
go so then you need to get to Juju yeah
they think future is a big thing in
Nigeria which is voodoo Juju is a big
crazy crazy thing in Nigeria my mom had
Juju stuff happen to her when she was
out there you know she got bit note
horses don't bite people she got bit on
the breast by a horse damn but it was
all kinds of crazy stuff that happened
to my mom out there even to me and my
brother when we were out there
um because they that that Juju stuff is
is legit
it's legit real yeah that's scary [__]
so now you come to the US yeah because
you lost everything we lost yeah
if I'm rich to poor like when I say poor
we had nothing and you had nothing I was
five my brother was six must be so
frustrating for your mom be like I told
you yeah this was gonna happen yeah yeah
you know what's hard for my mom but you
know my mom is a my mom's a beast though
you know my mom like to this day people
a lot of people follow on social media
she's 70 she's like a workout fanatic
she looks like she's 40. she like Health
fitness model pregnant
Pauline adelaiki so you look up Paulina
Instagram look her up you'll see she's
always doing Fitness stuff on there and
all that but uh but my mom she was just
a hard charger she was one of those
people that you know she had a hard life
growing up that's my mom
yeah she's seven she's gonna be she's
about to be 71. damn yeah she does
pull-ups and all that osteoporosis is
not welcome here
and through she's been through it and
back through hell man and so that that
and that's the that's the oh come on you
know that's
the woman that you know did it all so
wow wow when we got back into the states
um my mom made a phone call and this I
think this phone call was like the
trigger that
reminding her that no one's coming to
the rescue I got to make this happen on
our own she called up a family member a
very very close family member who she
grew up with
who was wealthy and uh my grandfather my
my mom's dad actually
helped raise this particular family
member and she said Hey listen I don't
have a nickel to my name
I and
I just need something to tie me over
until I can get on my couch and you know
figure out where I can get a job and
this and that my mom had a degree you
know in education and all that and so
um so he said let me call you back in
five minutes
five minutes later his wife called my
mom forward and the wife said to my mom
don't you ever call up my husband and
ask him for anything ever again and hung
up the phone on my mom here my mom just
lost her husband he's dead she's got two
boys don't know how to feed him take
care of him and then she gets kicked
while she's down at that point the
switch went off in her head and you know
it's interesting how things pass on
because there's been certain things that
has that have happened in my life where
switch went off in my head and I
completely was like okay I'm on my own
this is well not just that maybe just I
need to do things this way like this is
not going to happen I need to go through
this stuff same thing with my brother
like this is not gonna happen I need to
figure out a way to get through this
store and that's what my mom did so from
there on she worked multiple jobs I mean
dude she was always working she would
she would go to she would wake up in the
morning run the steps in our building up
we had 17 floors in our building
get me and my brother ready for school
get us fed drop us off let's walk us to
school go work one job me and my brother
will be in school she'll pick us up from
school
um come back help us with our homework
go work another job make dinner eat
dinner go work another job and so I had
a living example every day of a person
that didn't give up and could have given
and she never remarried she was just
like she she was a very beautiful woman
and she had guys that you know wanted to
get one and she was like I'm not dating
anybody dedicated I'm not marrying
anybody I'm gonna do this on my own by
myself and take care of my boy my mom I
asked my mom's like Mom why you know why
you never remarrying this she was like I
didn't want to bring any confusion
around you and your brother I I was you
and your brother was my everything and I
just knew that I needed to focus on you
guys and and because if you guys would
make it then everything would be okay
because she knew that my father's goal
for me and my brother was to make it and
be super successful and so that's that's
why she she did what she did and so you
know know she she tried man she tried
her best but you know as I got into my
um my teen years you know even before I
even got into my teen years growing up
in the Bronx you know the wrong route
you know drug dealers walking through
the park drug dealers selling drugs you
know crackheads you know playing
basketball getting jumped getting beat
up you know running walking my cousin
home in the middle of a shootout bullets
flying our way when all of that stuff
starts happening constantly you begin to
realize that the life that you once had
is not coming back and interestingly my
mom did such a great job at masking the
reality of what had happened that it
wasn't until I was like eight nine ten
and I realized that the life we once had
is not happening anymore like like our
apartment she had African art in there
she worked so there were times when my
mom didn't have enough food to feed
herself she had just enough food to feed
my brother and I so she would put the
food on the table and stand in the door
and watch us eat so we had our three
meals every day we had clothes and
shared clothes but they were things that
she went without and she did that in
order to protect us of the reality
yeah 100 I love that love that oh yeah
when did you realize you were you
weren't living royalty anymore yeah it
was like when I was talking to your ring
in a belly Dad yeah I remember man it
was you know it's so funny this whole
scene is fresh in my mind I had to I had
to condense it all the whole kind of
timeline in the screenplay because I got
hired to write the screenplay for for my
um for my book which is going to be a
film and so
I went to the park I kind of condensed
I'm condensing the story the same way I
condensed in the script but essentially
the events were I went to the park one
day playing basketball I got I got beat
beat up really bad I I got beat up by a
guy who was like 35 36 just I got out of
prison how old were you I was eight
years old god
um another guy was 16. I was playing
basketball against a kid who was my age
talking smack the way kids do he told me
to shut up I said if you don't if I
don't what are you gonna do he's like
I'm gonna go get your my brother I'm
like all right go get your brother Ben
I'm a kid I'm eight you know what I'm
saying his brother's 35. yeah yeah he
goes against his brother his brother was
17 his uncle was 35. damn he got them
and they they destroyed me man slam me
on the concrete beat me really I
remember I'll never forget there were
people all around the park just watching
doing nothing all around the park just
watching doing nothing and uh and I kind
of understand why these guys are drug
dealers knowing drug dealers they don't
want to get shot get killed whatever the
case may be you know after they got done
they held me down spit on me hit me a
couple more times and I got up
my brother walked me home and uh thank
God my brother wasn't there he had he
had kind of found out and came running
up but he you know he ran up like right
after they left which was a blessing and
they asked me they was like who's your
brother yeah and the reason why is
because everybody wants to people want
to know who you connected to so they
don't do something to to the per to you
and the person you connected to might be
somebody big and they come after them so
they asked me before they started who's
your brother and I said bio and it was
like what the hell is that anybody know
yeah yeah
right and so my brother walked me home
and
um you know I remember sitting on my bed
and staring at the picture on this our
raggedy dresser in our room and it was a
picture of my dad and me and him and my
and me him and my brother and I just
started crying about I just started
crying and uh my mom came into the room
and she was like Randy what's going on
what's going on and I was just like
We're not gonna have a life we used to
have anymore she's like what are you
talking about I was like dad's gone and
I was like I wish she was here so that
we could have a better life protected
you know protect me to provide so we can
have a better life and I was just I was
just like I was just crying so you got
sucked into the Whirlwind and I yeah and
I was that was the day I think I
unconsciously made the decision
to find a father in the streets
like that gangs and drugs through
through hip-hop culture Street culture
you know like a lot of kids in the inner
city that's the reality you look at
bronze Compton south side of Chicago
what are they looking at what do they
have that can show them the way or can
show them most of them don't have a
father figure in the house
yeah I think it's like 70 80 single
parent and and uh amongst other city
kids you know and so hip-hop was it was
the late 80s early 90s
big you know all these guys Jay-Z Snoop
all of this stuff so I was now able to
kind of hear a father see your father
through music videos every single as
much as I wanted to so when I went here
guys talk about yo somebody disrespect
you punch him in the face that's when I
really started fighting you know I
remember in in our park that I grew up
in the older kids they would get chalk
and draw a boxing ring like a box they
would draw a box with the chalk on the
cement and they would put the to the
young kids they would put us in the rain
you going against you and they would bet
and it was like you can't back down from
that it's like you're going in and
you're gonna get big you're gonna get
beat up you don't go ahead so I so I
would go in I started I was fighting I
was fighting I was stealing I was going
into bodegas and stealing chips stealing
this running out and then you know that
progressed to stealing from my mom the
little money that she had I would take
money from my under the mattress just so
I could try and you know flip it or do
something with then I remember times
when my mom you know she would came in
my room just crying she sat on my bed I
was like what's going on she's like I
had twenty dollars and my my bed and
it's gone I don't know what happened I
don't know what's going on like money
keeps missing I don't know what's going
on and she didn't suspect that it was
never yeah and so um the biggest thing
that I did before I even jumped before I
jumped to the drug stuff is you know I
uh my my dad's the engagement ring my
dad gave to my mom damn you sold it I
pawned it in in the pawn shop and uh
um you know that was that was that was
the craziest thing I did against my mom
and I remember watching her for years
destroy the house looking for that
engagement thing because that was the
only that was the only thing that she
had she had for my father damn you know
of value and I took and I pouring that
in because I wanted to get some money so
that I could do so I could buy some new
sneakers look fresh and at the end of
the day what it all boiled down to is
affirmation yep you know when a kid
doesn't have a father to affirm German
boy you know boys
the kicks look fly oh yeah
put a gun in and then and then we look
at athletes and you know just look at
John and some of these other people you
know the reality is what does it all
boil down to is like they're seeking
that affirmation that they didn't get
from their father you know even if it's
like even if they had a father maybe it
wasn't the proper form of Africa comes
from he has him on a good day yeah yeah
but I don't know if his dad is more like
a good I don't know yeah I'm just saying
yeah or amazing dad was just super
strict with the basketball yeah they've
tied fatherlessness too
suicide yeah I think something like 70
of boys that commit suicide are
fatherless almost all School shooters
are fatherless racial behavior is almost
all like if you if you incarcerate if
you look at how many people who are
incarcerated had no father yeah you need
a father 100 I mean you can solve so
many social ills with that that's why
conservative ideology is stay married
right yeah so a lot of cultures yeah
like so and there's dudes Turkish yeah
and he was going to get divorced from
his wife yeah what I'm gonna get
divorced he's an American dude but he
was married to a Turkish yeah and uh
well the the Turkish men and her family
from Turkey yeah showed up at his house
they had to sit there yeah yeah yeah
yeah they had to sit down there we ain't
doing this man they were like some
Americans
this is adorable that you think you're
going to get divorced you've got kids in
the house so what you're gonna do is
stay married now you're gonna be able to
do whatever you want but you're staying
married yeah yeah because otherwise it's
going to be a [__] dangerous
situation looks bad on me yeah like you
know what I mean like that that's like a
lot of cultures so so how far did you
get into that dark life yeah man I got
started selling drugs I would go on over
to Washington Heights buy weight from
Washington Heights I knew that there was
too many drug dealers in the Bronx every
corner was saturated with drug dealers
so I would jump on the Metro North and
go up to Poughkeepsie and what college
campuses up there to a good friend of
mine who I grew up with he moved from
the Bronx to Poughkeepsie because his
parents wanted to give him a better life
and I would just sell drugs up there got
to the point where a beginner man yeah
yeah my dad you know it all came from
that you know that that you know
diversifying and thinking two steps
ahead safer from Poughkeepsie too yes
much safer in Poughkeepsie for faster
colleges I think right I can't remember
man there's a lot of cars this was like
the 90s this was like yeah yeah and so
that progressed to getting into high
level scams so um I uh got this kind of
job at a company called I could say the
name now because the statue is a
limitation ran out but MCI WorldCom so
um when they came out when cell phones
first became like the thing
they were hiring the company a lot of
companies were hiring sales reps and so
I got a job there and what people were
doing illegally where they were
essentially
getting phones because you were able to
activate three phones on one person's
line of credit
and there was no real upfront fee and
essentially the person had 30 days to 30
days before they received their bill
then 30 days later
it was when it was due and then if it
wasn't paid at the 60-day Mark then 90
days later it would cut off and so so
you had three months of of a phone and
so what a lot of the people at the
office I was working out of was doing
they were hustling so they would get
people's line of credit date of birth
social security uh full name and they
would activate three phones on one
person's line of credit and sell those
phones unlimited I was I mean I was
doing unlimited cell phone plans before
that that even existed I think I'm the
one that came up with that yeah
90 days
yeah making money yeah as a sales rep as
a Salesman legally so so legally but so
um so I had an added Niche because I had
because all the drug dealers like that
concept so all because all the drug
dealers could have a phone for 90 days
get rid of it
pop smoke go to the next one and so the
guy in the office kind of put me on to
it and then I just ran with it and so I
was bringing in like ten thousand a week
I was making stupid money giving my
money back to Mama or no yeah we ain't
giving my mom's money got you know
paying off stuff with the drug getting
getting out of the drug game all
together and you know I was selling
two-way pages I don't know if you
remember the Motorola two-way page one
man I was selling those I was selling
those for like 500 a pop I was selling
phones for like depending on the phone
300 if it was a standard phone up to
like 700 if it was like the Motorola Tic
Tac yeah it looked like a Tic Tac flip
phone little one so I was selling those
for like 700 so I was making crazy money
and um at the same time I wanted to be
in a music business and so I started a
record company called Eighth Wonder
Eighth Wonder records and I had artists
on me and we were essentially put
together compilation albums I was paying
for studio time I was paying for us to
go go do music and venues printing CDs
all that I was able to essentially
launder the money through the record
company yeah and my goal was to make a
certain amount make a large enough
amount of money to be able to go full
time with The Muse
but a lot of people have that plan yeah
but then they're like oh I'm gonna get
out after my next time yeah yeah
and if so how how everything went South
for me was I met this one drug dealer
and he was essentially the My Demise in
that business because
um one day you know we were doing
business for a couple months and then
one day he reached out to me he was like
hey I want to I want to buy a bulk and I
was like buying bulk what you mean it's
like I want to buy it I want to buy like
10 10 20 phones at the time I was like I
don't do that because I said I said a
number of phones that I would sell a
week so that things wouldn't get too hot
and another thing that I did was I have
a friend of mine who I went to high
school with his girlfriend worked at
hospice so he would get me
social date of birth from the hospice
because
they're about to die yeah so that's kind
of how I was able to keep it yeah yeah
I'm on the end when you pour used to get
out quick
but then someone always comes along and
[__] it up being smart trying to get on
everybody's radar
and he was like and I was like I was
like no I'm not doing it but he was very
convincing so finally I was like all
right I'll do it but I'll just try it
out for a month
bro after 30 days of that first order
all the phones cut off
and when that happened literally I
damned that [__] myself because there
were people that were getting caught and
sent to Federal getting prosecuted and
charged federally for that in my office
in my office in my office and so
none of the phones had ever cut off that
early so when they cut off in my head I
was like oh my God when he called me he
was he was hot he called me and
threatened me he was like yo the phone's
cut off I'm coming to your house right
now and I'm like all right he's gonna
come kill me that's the least of my
worries yeah like one of my what's going
to happen with the you know with the FED
time yeah and that was the first thing
that was on my mind I was like man I
could talk my way out of getting shot
but I can't talk my way out of federal
prison it's just too I didn't sold too
many phones and there's people in my
office getting caught and getting walked
out of the office and handcuffed and so
uh uh so I came to my house threatened
me with a gun and then I made him his
money I gave him I had money in my house
so I gave him large stack him one next
day met him gave him the rest of the
money and then I was like all right I'm
done with this you had to get money
because what he did was he flipped the
phones so if I sold him the phone I sold
him bulk if I sold him want all their
phones for 300 I can't remember the
exact number but if I sold each phone
for 300 he then went and sold it for 600
each phone so he had to go
300 so you owe him all that money so I
had to get it now not a guy you want to
[__] with not a definitely you know he
was a Jamaican dude he was a big drug
dealer because you sound like hey man
you're the reason we're in this mess
you're the one to do bulk dumbass yeah
it kind of yes or no because part of it
could have been him but it could have
been just the whole gig was up yep you
know just it gives us you know and so
um my point I was just trying to figure
out how to how do I talk myself that was
one thing I was always good at I was
always good at like talking myself yeah
talking my way out of the situation I
got myself into so after I gave my money
I was like damn like how am I going to
do this I gotta I can't I can't just not
show up anymore I can't just not go into
the office because then then you know
yeah yeah so and I need to I need for my
own mental stability I need to find out
what's going on so I had my mom help me
write a letter
and I wrote a letter to the manager of
the office and I was just I was like Hey
listen like I got a better job offer
things are getting crazy I just want to
get out of this crazy business and do
something different because in my naive
mind this is how stupid I was I figured
that if I left if I quit before I'm not
gonna fire me
in my mind I was like they can't fire me
if I quit already if I quit and left the
job then they can't fire me and
prosecute me because I'm not there you
thought the feds would read that like no
you moved up here anymore never mind
there's no case just move on from this
guy he wrote us a nice letter exactly I
didn't know I didn't know what I was
thinking I don't know if somebody told
me that but I was just like yeah maybe
the feds but that was that's what I was
thinking if I quit then they can't
prosecute me because I quit so I went in
and I went into the office building it
was right on 42nd Street
by Grand Grand Central Station went up
the step scared to death looking around
as I'm walking through the office ah the
fast am I gonna pop out on me walk
through the cubicles I went straight to
the manager's office there's a lady
named Miss green and uh and I and she
said come in I came in I was like Hey
and first I had to set you know get it
get engaged for the temperature so she
was like oh so she was super nice she's
like come on in Remy come on I'm like
all right good I think I think I'm all
right she said she's acting man it seems
all right so I sit down she's like what
does it run me I was like Hey listen I
was like I'm leaving and I just want to
give you this letter and it's nice she's
like why why are you leaving and she got
she got like a bit hot so I was like oh
man is this it does she give me and then
she dialed it back she was like no don't
leave don't leave it's like
finally I finally realized that she was
meaning well because you know in the
streets of the Bronx you learn how to
read people and I finally realized that
she was she was her spirit was in the
right yeah
because she started crying yeah she was
just like I don't want you to be so or
she's the best actor ever or she's a bad
but she wasn't yeah
she didn't really know so she didn't
know yeah so so and I said I was like
you know I hear guys that are getting
arrested for the cell phone thing like I
can't believe you're doing that I was
like yeah I can't believe it I'll be
involved I don't want to get involved in
none of that she's like no you won't
you're good I know you're not you and I
check out I would I wasn't just making
money on what I was doing illegally I
was getting Commission on all those
sales so I was a top salesperson in the
office oh that's why she didn't want you
to leave either that was another reason
why she didn't want me to leave you're
probably likable yeah you're killing us
I'm killing it on both ends I'm getting
she get he's handing me five thousand
dollars three thousand dollar commission
checks and I'm getting 10 000 a week so
I'm making crazy money I bought a brand
new Lincoln car I mean straight off the
dealership everything did you ever play
her mom's ring back or no no no that was
long gone I was I did that when I was
like 12. I was like 19 at this point and
so um so she accepted my resignation and
she said don't worry you're never gonna
get caught up I know you would never do
anything like this and she said good
luck and at that point I like I felt
like I got away but for years man years
even when I was in the military I was
always worried something on my shoulder
like look around look around it might be
there look around look around it might
be there so they don't care that's
usually the limitation we're good right
or do you want to edit all this out I'm
good I should be good you leave hair
fans are out there they're not going to
be like that company was bankrupt you
ripped them off yeah our company's going
they ripped off a lot of people in other
ways anyway yeah man so uh so yeah so
that was that was December of 2001 like
you know three months after 9 11 and um
the next month and or went hard with the
record company like that's when I went I
remember having a meeting at Def Jam I
uh I I shared a story with uh um with
Joe Budden's manager because Joe Buttons
has his podcast I was talking to talk
about getting big podcast yeah he and he
uh I went to the depth Channel office
and I had a meeting with Kevin Lyles he
was big the guy big producer and big
executive and uh had the compilation
album that I spent all this money to
make and I played a form
play like one song he liked his second
song he liked the third song He's not in
his head I'm like I might get a label
deal because that's where Rockefeller
got a label deal murder ain't got a
label deal that's what I was trying to
do I was like that's gonna save me so
now all the money I invested is now
paying off I get the money back and now
we could you know do the music thing and
uh after like the seventh song he
stopped it and he said you he's like
that's cool but you ain't hit something
fire you want to hit something dope and
as soon as he said that I knew that
wasn't your label deal what was dope
Kanye Joe Buttons oh yeah so he was like
so he was like I just signed this guy
named Joe Buttons and he pulls out the
CD it was like blanket it didn't have
any graphics or anything he ain't
putting in the CD player it was Joe one
of Joe Buttons first singles that
dropped he played he's like that's gonna
hit he's gonna be the biggest rapper in
New York he's gonna be the biggest
rapper and at that point you know before
that I checked out yeah yeah I was like
yeah whatever place it could have been
anything right did you hear a difference
between Joe Buttons and the guy that you
the guys that you had Oh I thought my
guys were fired yeah yeah I thought my
guys were great I mean I mean to this
today I I listened to the album from
time to time and I'm like yo this is
when I was writing the screenplay I put
I put some of the songs in there lyrics
I was like yo this was fire man I even
got a verse on one of the songs yo this
is tight and uh but it didn't work out
and then you know January passed nothing
February passive money goes away I have
nothing left
you know March April and then finally in
June you know my mom got tired of me
sitting in the house and not getting a
job and I got tired of me sitting in the
house and hoping on something hoping for
something to happen and uh that's when I
made the decision you know what
you know what else do I have to lose
like the idea kind of is a lot more to
the story but in short I was laying in
my bed and I felt this presence I felt
something to say to me you need to get
out of here you need to join the
military and it was a June morning and I
remember getting out of the bed looking
around and because I it sounded like
somebody had spoken to me and I didn't
see anybody didn't hear my mom my mom
was in her room and then that thought
just began to linger and linger and
linger did it sound like Jocko or was it
I wake up at 4 30 in the morning small
calm voice and then
started battling with the idea because I
hated the police I Associated anybody in
the uniform as a police officer make
sense with your background yeah whether
you Army Navy Marine Corps you were the
police to me
um I had a great disdain for the
American government you know what I mean
just growing up hearing what I heard and
you know even stuff that I saw growing
up you know seeing cops beat the brakes
off of dudes and train stations me being
arrested having crazy stuff happened I
just had a lot of distance is this 2001
you said this is 2000 so it's after so
this is 2000 this is 2002. okay so after
September 11th yeah yeah you know the
tower yeah I watch The Towers come down
I remember going
um uh going to the roof of uh of my
building with this girl while I was
dating at the time and we we saw the
tower smoking and we saw it come down
from the roof and her cousin was in
Windows of the world
she was a waitress in Windows of the
world they never found is that the
restaurant yeah
yeah that that that that to see those
Towers fall was so unbelievable for our
New Yorkers yeah yeah it was it was like
hard to even understand yeah yeah it was
crazy it was tough for everybody yeah
but it brought it brought it it brought
New York together
you know what I mean like whether you're
a black white cotton eye you know
whatever the case may be it was like I
was nervous 11 days after that so you
know the deal yeah yeah we saw it
smoking I'm still smoking yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah well we flew over it I saw it
and then did you did that give even when
that happened we were like man I think
in the military was this voice Tony no
it was unfortunate because that happened
I was nine months earlier so I felt the
voice and then I was like I battled for
a bit but then I looked at my dad's
picture that same picture that I cried
in front of when my you know when I came
home after getting beat up and uh I said
you know Screw what else do I have to
lose you know let me see what's going to
happen and uh ran down the street I grew
up on Fordham Road and First I went into
the Marine Corps office because I was
like oh you know I joined the Marines
you know I mean there was a poster in
there this guy with a gun and a wetsuit
and I was like oh that's a Navy Seal cat
because I didn't know the difference
because I watched a movie called The
Rock yep but you know there were two
movies that kind of planted the seat in
my head to do something outside of
Sports drugs and rapping and that was
bad boys because that was the first time
I saw two black dudes who looked like me
but they were cool and they were Heroes
and then it was a rock because that was
the first time I saw these Navy Seals I
was like yo these dudes got a rubber
suits and swimming they got cars they're
driving the water and I was like if I
ever turn my life around I'll do that so
when I went to Marine Corps recruiter's
office I saw that post I was like Ah
that's right I'm gonna be a Navy SEAL
thinking that the Marine Corps cut out
as an ABCO nobody was in the office I
sat there for like 10-15 minutes and
nobody came nobody came they were there
was coffee on the desk damn recruiters
it was coffee on the desk so somebody
must have been taking a dump or
something yeah but the guy didn't come
they had bad cell service yeah hey you
had to go outside
full circle yeah but it was it was a
blessing because I went two door two
doors down to the Navy recruiter's
office walked in there it was a
beautiful Puerto Rican Navy recruiter
named Tiana Nadine Reyes damn you still
remember her name remember her name and
uh I saw one in my mind I was like yo
I'm yo I'm not just getting in the Navy
but I'm I'm getting with her
and so I'm I'm that's why she got the
job yeah that's why she got a job so I
started swabbing on her and she's
laughed she was from the Bronx she
served in the Navy and then she came
back to be a recruiter in the Bronx
because she wanted to kind of get back
to her community and uh and uh she's
like what do you want to do I was like
yeah I'm gonna be a Navy SEAL she's like
you you gonna be a Navy soon because I
was skinny yeah and she was like I was
like she was like I was like damn be a
girl be a seal so she's like whatever
she's like come over here Navy SEAL and
take the practice ASVAB test so I went
to the computer took a practice ASVAB
test I passed high enough to get into
the Navy but I didn't pass high enough
to be a seal because you got to score
really high on the ASVAB test
it's like a aptitude test it's almost
like the SAT oh God you know so it's a
it's a you know it's like math and
reading comprehension and all these like
it's like it's like the SAT but just to
get into the military [__] and so um
after that she had me come over to her
desk went over to her desk and she ran
my back yeah
and when she ran my background she found
I had two warrants out for my arrest
and when she said that bro my whole body
guy you didn't even know I didn't even
know I had warrants damn I didn't even
know I had warrants my whole body got
high to keep in mind I left I left
Worldcom in December
so in my mind the first thing that
popped in my mind I'm like oh my God
these are the FED warrants they they
couldn't find me they're coming after me
I'm going to Fed federal prison dude it
was like I wanted to die my whole body
is turned pale every I got high my face
turned pill and I got up and I I bolted
towards the door and right before I got
to the door she stopped me she said stop
I'm like I'm like what I'm sweating at
this point I'm like and she's like
where you going it's like I'm getting
out of here like God I was like I don't
know I'm just I'm just getting out of
here she's like say I was like no I'm
not staying [__] I thought she was going
to turn me in I thought she was trying
to call the cops to turn me in and uh I
was like what do you want she's like are
you gonna turn me in she's like no no
I'm not gonna turn you in she's like
just relax it's chill she said you got a
suit I said I said no I ain't got no
suit she said she was asking out on a
date I thought she was trying to take me
to the pen for your court yeah I thought
she was taking it was going to take me
to to the cops and she wanted me dressed
nice so that when she takes me they they
have leniency this is what I'm thinking
yeah so then she's like she's like you
got a collar shirts some nice pants I
was like I'm sure I could find something
why why I'm amped up you know I grew up
on DMX so I'm like yeah you know why
what what do you want
and then uh she's like just come back
tomorrow like for what she said just
come back tomorrow she screamed at me in
a New York accent
and I looked at her like I said growing
up in the Bronx I learned how to read
people
so you have to especially when you're
hustling the way I'm hustling so I was
able to read that I can't I don't know
exactly what she's going to do for me
but she's going to do something good
that's authentic yeah and so I said all
right
I came back the next day she was in her
dress uniform head to toe metals and
everything
she drove me to New Jersey I had a
warrant in New Jersey drove me to New
Jersey and and I was even more petrified
because the headquarters for my company
was in New Jersey
drove me to New Jersey found out that
the the uh
it's got me in front of the judge it was
for like reckless driving awesome when I
was going recording in the studio or
something like nothing I was yeah I was
like I was doing like 120 and like
something ridiculous and I never showed
up the court and so it was reckless
driving misdemeanor
so she told the judge she said listen
this guy's made mistakes he's trying to
he's drawing trying to join the military
after 9 11. you know this is a
courageous act for him to make that
decision you know patriotism yada yada
and the judge said hey if this guy's
serious about joining the military after
an act of War Alex sponger's record
clear all this oh yes he's pay the court
fees and court fines boom that's done
get to New York I had a case that you
know
resisting arrest in a bunch of CR it was
a bad it was a bad charge not like it
wasn't felony or anything crazy it
wasn't like a murder to rape somebody
but it was it was a it was a charge it
was a charge of something I did that I
totally forgot that did that I got
arrested for went to jail for but never
went to went to court for it I skipped
Court I missed court you made bail and
got the [__] out I got out and and I
never went I I'm not thinking I'm young
I'm not thinking I got to go to court
male I mean even now we get summonses to
do jury duty I forget my only reminder
is my my Apple calendar
and uh and so I got charged for that and
so same thing she went in front of the
judge and and said the same thing as
kids made mistakes but he has potential
and the courthouse was coincidentally
like five blocks away from 911 the top
the twin towers and so the judge was
like yo if this guy's serious like the
other Judge Alex sponger's record he
just has to pay the court fees and core
funds and uh you know he thanked me for
joining the military for you know after
and after War
she had to go a step further she went a
step further and fudged the paperwork
because even with my record expunged she
still needed time that doesn't clear in
the system right away for the government
the military background check system she
fudged all of that I love her yeah
she died two years later oh no damn for
months yeah she had an autoimmune
disease damn but her daughter you know
her man I'm cool her family her
daughter's like my daughter I'm flying
out here in July you know for for uh for
holiday because she just graduates she
graduates high school oh wow moms are
like my mom's we on the tax thread
texting her mom's her dad so their
family her brother's like my brother uh
so Brad Brad you know Brad is hung out
with the family with Cece and Sierra and
and the family so yeah we all family now
because that decision
that I've accomplished my fan I wouldn't
have anything that I have now it just
shows you just need somebody to take a
chance that's it that's it she saw a
little believe she saw something yeah
and you got yourself in that recruiting
thing yeah yes yeah did you did you uh
yeah and you you joined the seals join
the Navy so I joined the Navy and uh
you know went to boot camp and when I
got to boot camp I wanted to do the seal
thing but I couldn't because I didn't
have the ASVAB scores and I remember
seal came in too he came into our
division and he did like a presentation
in the auditorium and showed us like a
video of seals like skydiving driving
dune buggies dude that had long hair and
beers and they got suppressors on that
gun like it was actual Navy sealing and
all of us in there like 200 cats like yo
like and uh afterwards he was like who
wants to go screen because he had to
scream to get in which is like a 500
yard swim push-ups sit-ups a mile and a
half run and pull-ups in a certain
amount of time
and all the guys that had qualified with
the ASVAB left the room and who wanted
to do it and I was left there with all
the cats that didn't want to do it and I
was that crushed me that like crushed me
because I was like dude I want to be
with those dudes but that was like my
fuel like and that's something like I
said that switch Yeah that had like that
like a switch went off my head and I was
like
come hella high water I'm gonna figure
this swimming thing out this academic
thing out this physicality thing out
imagine growing up in the front you
weren't doing a lot of swimming ah man
there's no swims man there's fire
hydrants you pop the fire hydrants
inner city guys black guys yeah yeah and
like they're all amazing athletes not
one can swim where would you swim yeah
swimming is kind of rich kids
thing but in New York where the [__] you
gonna swim or not yeah yeah so you have
to teach yourself to swim so I got to my
first command which was Naval Hospital
Camp Pendleton and I was out in the
Boondocks and it was a blessing and I
got stationed out there because I was
out in the Boondocks like literally our
Hospital once you drove through the Camp
Pendleton Gates it was a half an hour
drive to the hospital and the hospital
was like literally in this desert area
surrounded by nothing so as soon as I
got to the uh to the command to the
hospital
check it with my LP and I was like
listen I want to be a seal but I need to
train I need to be able to train and I
was I was stationed at a Family Practice
Clinic so I was like checking in babies
doing Vital Signs just like a nurse and
so um she was like all right if you work
four hours in the morning I'll give you
four hours off in the afternoon then you
come back and work the night oh that's
cool and so again somebody another woman
that was like yeah I believe in this I
believe in you you know what I mean and
uh and what fueled me to be on my best
behavior was that decision that Tiana
made to get me because the reason why
she had to fudge the paperwork was
because the government's policy was if
you had a record we need to know what it
was we didn't know what you did so that
we could make the decision because if we
don't know what you did we don't know if
you're going to do that and again in the
military yes so you know rightly so the
government military's policy was right
on because they don't want somebody if
you're rapist or serial killer or a
thief or whatever to come into doing
that and so I wanted to show that I was
truly rehabilitated I wanted to do well
to the best of my ability so Tiana's
decision was made right so I could pay
pave the way for other kids because I
get messages to this day
from kids were like yo I had this charge
you know making a threat to my
girlfriend or whatever or trespassing or
whatever to know your life no no one
won't let me into the military no Branch
won't take there's no touch it yeah man
and so like and I'm like and he's like
what's what what can I do and I'm always
like you gotta find that one recruiter
that's gonna take that risk man like
there's nothing I could do I wish I
could do it for you if it was up to me
I'd put you in but you might be able to
you might be able to appeal to Congress
you might be able to go hey there are
kids who made one mistake in the
military could use them give them a
chance you could just testify to
Congress a guy like you I tried he could
yeah for the kids you need politicians
kids get a no there's nothing like I'm
gonna go to Congo you would need you
would need a special bill passed and say
like sort of the second chance law or
something like that that's a good idea
it's something I got to consider doing
it's a very good you could do it because
there are a lot of you get very
sympathetic years especially now and yes
you would get it from Republicans and
Democrats yeah yeah yes that's something
Republicans are not going to say you
made a mistake hey there are kids
able-bodied kids who have potential yeah
you can let them waste away because they
made one mistake because they're 18.
yeah or 17 or 16. yeah or you can give
them a chance and change life around
every Republican get beyond that because
that's a patriotic thing yeah Democrats
might do it but like we'll we'll expunge
the crime but they got to be trans every
yeah
that's true Democrats will do it if it
if it's uh
a lot of these kids are kids of color
yeah yeah so they're black and they're
brown so Democrats aren't about to be
like no the Democrats are definitely the
party now of the second third and
fourths that's why you know those
sorrows prosecutors yeah but left or
right we're talking about military yeah
we need this yeah you could you could
actually recruiting right now recruiting
that's horrible make a real difference I
was one of the heads of recruiting
yesterday we had lunch he was like yo
Remy he's like it's bad bro he's like
it's like Nationals security level it's
bad
Army Navy across the board is down if we
have if a war popped off right now
fat kids
do you think you want to send that kid
into a [__] really experienced pilot
at United yesterday yeah at a party a
kid's party and he said we have such a
staff shortage uh for for people first
of all who are like you know traffic
control guys so that's why planes are
delayed a lot of times but also they
can't find Pilots so they're putting
they're putting younger and younger more
and more inexperienced yeah and and he
was like I'm telling you right now it's
a matter of time yeah but what was but
what started this I don't go down this
road and get this episode flagged what
started it with the Mandate I know
exactly so all the pilots like oh okay
well we're not getting I know and shut
down in general yeah there you go
there's a lot of that thank you and then
also you gotta think about a lot of
people who are pilots or all you know
air crew or I don't know what you're
calling guys a lot of them come from the
military they get the experience in the
military then they they retire get out
and then they go into the civilian
sector but now because of the the lack
of recruiting we're now seeing the
effects of people not having joined so
they're not getting out how about this
so I was raving about the border and
it's open and all these people coming to
a raven that's a good thing no I'm
raving against it we should close the
board okay I had to be clear smart dude
it's really smart dude he's a
billionaire yeah and he's my friend and
he uh he goes uh he calls himself
Republican like Democrat heavy anyways
he goes here's the thing dude we have a
labor shortage in this country yeah and
all those people coming over all of them
are getting jobs yeah jobs that we don't
want yeah and they're paying taxes and I
was like it is he showed me the stats he
follows it he's way smarter than I am he
has all and I was like this I was like
oh yeah I mean I was like maybe I should
rethink some of what I'm saying I was
like oh okay no you definitely need
immigrants for a lot of that stuff yeah
you can't say every person a lot of them
are getting jobs a lot of them coming in
because they're because there's a lot of
Labor shortages for sure [__] that
people don't want to do it so it has to
be a process for that you just I agree
I'm not saying you know I agree I'm not
saying I believe in you know legal
immigration and their friend didn't amen
is your friend named Soros right yeah be
careful with this one you don't trust
him wait so now let's get back to it
I'm an American Patriot let's get back
to so you you end up um you now now you
want to be a Navy sealer yeah yeah well
I just want to back up for a second just
on the military I'm loving your story
not thank you brother it's like a movie
I'm watching yeah it's going to be it's
gonna be a firewood too but uh
the military needs people and I'm you
know I just want not to you know step on
your platform and stuff but hey you know
to tell people listen it was great for
me and it's great for young people if
you don't know what you want to do dude
you get you get paid good money get to
travel the world I got my bachelor's and
my Master's paid for I they paid me to
go to college to get my bachelor's in
relationships relationships uh it gives
you a platform that you could jump off
to later listen I wish supporters he's
not support I'm a supportive of my
entire family yeah yeah I want to go the
military yeah VA loan if you want to buy
a house so I tell you I know there's
been a push
I I think is a lot of it is politicized
I think a lot of people they see
military and they're like oh that's
that's a Republican or a red type type
thing social media though yeah
that's not real that's not real the
military is [__] great it's amazing
we have the biggest baddest military in
all the [__] lands but there's only
one skills too yeah but and there's only
one way to keep that number one spot by
you guys enroll 100 and it's diverse the
military is the most important I worked
with that the first time I was I was
around a ton of white dudes was in the
middle when I got the boot camp I'm like
oh snap I never see this color doesn't
matter because color doesn't matter and
it's all about the God to your right or
the woman to your left or whoever the
case may be in getting the job done and
there's so many life lessons that come
out of joining the military so I just
wanted to use this this this
um this opportunity to just make an
appeal to young people listen man I'm a
dude from I grew up in the Bronx I came
from nothing you know and I'm not trying
to say I'm not trying to boast when I
say this but the military has given me a
platform where I'm wealthy now I'm very
wealthy my kids won't have to work
unless I want them to my kids College is
already paid for because of the military
so just think about that think about the
opportunities that could come your way
think about your future it's not just
about the hearing I think so many people
especially young kids they forget that
at some point you're gonna die I'm gonna
die we're over 100 years from now 99 of
the people on this planet will not be on
this planet anymore that's just a
reality the only thing you could leave
behind is your legacy is your legacy and
and and leave behind something for your
kids and your grandkids and all of that
and we are in the we live in the
greatest country and I I have no shame
in saying that because I came from
another country you know what I'm saying
you know my father left the West Rich
went to Nigeria died poor I left Nigeria
poor came to America I'm rich and a lot
of that came from the opportunities
that the military afforded to me also
the workout I think you learned the
discipline exactly translation
everything you're doing exactly exactly
so I know a lot of you
just toughness in general I'm joining
the [__] in general don't don't be
careful yeah I heard that I heard they
lowered they lowered the age required
yeah well I move like I'm 30. there you
go
so man so so keep going so now yes get
to the let's get this now you see did
you go through buds yeah so I well first
I had to train and I trained I put the
pedal to the metal as soon as she gave
me those four hours I bought an asvash
with Dummies book I got I you know I got
some swim gear I got uh this uh buds two
three four it's like Navy SEAL training
documentary a lot of [__] I wrote it
yeah and I just created a regiment you
know what I mean I studied my ASVAB Book
for a certain amount of hours and went
to the gym and swam just did that
religiously and like within within six
months I took him passive screening test
I went from not being able to swim to
being able to swim and passing the
screening test not being able to do a
push-up to doing 30 pull-ups and 100
push-ups and I was just and I tell
people all the time anytime you have a
dream you there's always going to be an
obstacle on on the path towards that
dream otherwise it wouldn't be called a
dream it would be cool otherwise
everyone would do it everybody every
time you do it and you can make one or
two choices either you could throw your
hands up and play victim oh you know
this all that I can't do it or you could
do the extra extra hard work to overcome
that deficiency so that you could
achieve your dream and so I chose to do
the extra extra hard work whether it was
raining whether it was cold whether I
was sick I ran to that pool uphill three
miles uphill jump in the pool freezing
cold try to figure it out ran three
miles back to the barracks did something
else and I did that religiously past the
screening test and within a year
checking into the command my Naval
Hospital cam Pendleton I was checking
out and on my way to Seal training damn
and and that's when that's right that's
when the picture that's when it got real
sure it got real it got real bunches
Buzz is insane huh listen man I was at
the buzz yesterday I took Danny Amendola
who was on the fox show with me I love
it he's a good dude yeah really good I
took him and his girlfriend and gave him
a tour right yeah yeah Patriots two two
jobs like you're [__] attitude
my hands are starting to get hot what's
this time I see you might see a toss-up
right now does this happen because no
words just tough because you're kind of
a simp and we're here right bro my
billionaire friends the board is fine
there's no issues with the board
Kamala Harris 2024. I'd say that I
that conversation never happened did it
what your friend billinger with the
Border I don't have a billion and then
the pilot all right keep going yeah keep
going yeah so yeah when I got there was
crazy man it was relentless man
um Class 250 was my first class
do a lot of Legends in that class Mikey
Monsour who went on to win the Medal of
Honor he was in my class and my boat
crew uh Workman who ended up you know he
got shot down at Extortion 17 he was in
my class my my boat crew Ryan Jo rolled
into that class he was another guy
Silver Star task force Bruiser I mean it
was it was just Peppers was that
chocolate Willis yeah yeah yeah was it
was there a moment when you're like in
buds with all those badasses and you're
badass yourself we're like holy [__] man
yeah this is every day was humbling bro
every day when I do when when day one of
buds
and we started like 4 35 and five in the
morning I can't remember the exact time
it was still dark and they called us out
on that grinder we ran out there it was
like Saving Private Ryan when the boats
were coming in yeah and like and cats
are getting shot and and then you all in
the characters POV and bullets are
flying it was like that we running in
and instructors are just like 20 of them
I get down and guys just falling on
stuff getting hurt quitting ringing the
bell ding ding ding then another person
Runner it was gnarly man explain us with
water holes
would you get confidence when they would
ring the bell 100 we we had a saying it
was like uh Highlander it was like
Highlander when you kill a dude and you
get it nowhere near is what I went
through any similar to buds but yeah
well you know I played football at
University of Colorado they called Dirty
dozens yeah yeah you'd have to be there
at 4 30 a.m before our classes yeah so
there's probably 150 guys and the only
point was to get guys to quit yeah yeah
like anybody who couldn't finish the
Sprints or finish the obstacles they
would
anyone who fell down out yeah and it
used to give me so much energy yeah when
a guy yeah because in your mind it's
like well I was yeah I'm better than it
yeah exactly and that was the thing
falling off from that belly like yes it
gives you this energy that you wouldn't
believe yeah it was they were sorry
I want to hear their end of the story
okay
I remember there was a guy in my class
who was a he this is when triathlons
became really big and he was like all
instructors knew him because he was like
a well-known triathlete dude quit and
hey I'm a cat who just learned how to
swim I'm from the Bronx I'm like one of
three black dudes in a class at 250
because not too many black dudes go to
buds you know they're getting the buds
and it's just empowers you but it was
man it was brutal man isn't a lot of it
mental like I'm sure like the athletes
like the best people don't realize like
oh I bet LeBron would do buds like no no
no no yeah the mental fortitude it's so
mental it's mental it's all mental it's
100 once you pass the screening test a
500 yard swim push-ups sit-ups all that
stuff you've already essentially told
the Navy and yourself that you are
physically qualified to make it through
SEAL training the question doesn't
become physicality anymore yes the
instructors are using physical tools to
drive home intellectual points it's all
yeah extreme discomfort extreme cold I
mean my lowest core temperature at one
point was 88.8 they will certain they
serve torture the hell out of us and
that's a way to get that's how they get
rid of the majority of the guys is the
cold the the cold shivering shivering
insanity
the cold is it's like it's like the
worst thing ever that you will ever
because you can't escape it you know and
how long is buds is six months God I
said it was weeks it's not six months
it's six months bro stupid six months
you [__] get it together
and then and then but then then sleep
too yeah so so the third the third
month of that with some classes the
third week is hell week some classes are
fourth week is hell week so hell week is
an evolution where they keep you up for
six days it starts on Sunday it ends on
Friday it's straight tortures everything
you did you over the past two previous
two weeks you know live PT boats on
heads we're running with the boat on
your head feels like your neck is gonna
break uh lunges uh swims like you're wet
they keep you wet the entire time to the
point where Thursday of Hell Week
everybody's pretty much hydrophobic
which means you're terrified of the
water because they've kept you start
shivering when you think about them
think about the water I've heard that
it's it's miserable and then Friday is
when it ends they said you get two hours
of sleep on Wednesday starts on Sunday
you get two hours of sleep on Wednesday
two hours of sleep on Thursday but by
that time you're so wired most guys
can't even fall asleep by that point
because you're so because you're just
expecting them to wake you up any second
and can you use any like caffeine
nothing nothing they don't give you
coffee no caffeine no any no no okay
but there's been guys who tried to cheat
it and went into hell week with like
some type of caffeine drug or something
they die damn hell week yeah yeah a guy
died in my class not because he was on
anything because he had a he had an
underlying heart issue this is what I
remember I could be wrong but that
wasn't reported and and because he
wanted to be a seal dude he died right
in front of him on the beat we were on a
conditional run which was a five my six
mile run in soft Sands horrible as a
Friday it was the last evolution of the
day and they have a thing called the
Goon Squad where if you don't make a
certain cutoff point if you're so far
behind they stop you and they just
Hammer you me up and down the berm bear
crawls in the ocean bad push-up
assistant and he he died right in front
of me damn they were I worked on them
and a few other Coleman worked on them
trying to revive and they finally got a
post but he had been out so long that by
the time they got into the hospital it
was a vegetable damn and so it's it's
it's it's brutal bro it's like and you
can you can't cheat in and take
something there's been guys who tried to
cheat
there's no way around yeah yeah I almost
died as a matter of fact I ended up the
first time I went to hell week I got the
Tuesday hell week with two five zero
um I got pneumonia I started with
pneumonia because we had a med check the
date the two days before how we started
and I was already spitting up blood and
I knew as a corpsman I knew I had
pneumonia but I didn't want to report it
how'd you get it just not sleep just
being in the water being cold you know
you're around some people can't keep in
and something like I do super well in
the heat yeah I wouldn't last I can't
handle the cold I just my neck is too
long some [__] maybe I'm too shredded
notice how aggressive we've gotten with
each other
they're like we're about to we're about
to attack you know I like Brian stops
you and he goes the thing about I mean I
you know I don't know if I could be in
it
no we all no we know everyone watching
he looked at me and he goes like this he
goes secretly you weren't here I love
you guys the first time I met him he
went he went like this he goes you and
the teams I went and I just I winked
secrecy so now did you guys so you so
Tuesday you you have to drop out so no
no I didn't drop off
I don't quit brother okay
yeah
so historians there so I quit yeah
so uh yeah I had I was spitting up blood
before I started and I knew I had
pneumonia but I didn't want to report it
because I didn't want to start day one
of first phase over again because at
that in that class I did three weeks of
first phase which is hella I mean we
lost like 90 dudes in those three weeks
I didn't want to start from day one
that's why you lose the most yeah that's
when you lose most of the hell week
that's when you lose pretty much the
rest and then a lot of hell was like how
we just graduated Class 12 guys got
through that whole week that was like
you know a couple months okay so so I'm
sorry but so you're saying you lose a
lot of people just up to hell week you
lose a lot of people those first three
was like day one you lose a lot of
people then day two then you got that
week you've lost a good chunk of the
class maybe a quarter to class because
you're not nothing that much then either
now you get done like depending on the
evolutions you get done like around
maybe seven o'clock sometimes you have a
night Evolution like 10 o'clock but even
when you get done with instructors you
still got to clean your gear clean your
room sharpen your knife so you're not
going to bed till late anyway then you
got to be up at like five in the morning
the next day to get ready for evolution
how good did it feel when you passed bro
last moment ever it was it was it was
yeah it was it was Heaven you made
through you made it through hell week
yeah so I I ended up almost dying to
hell we went to the ICU uh got pulled on
Tuesday went to the ICU was in the ICU
for like a week uh when pneumonia site
rabdo oh we oh you had rap though too
yeah it's my muscle tissue breaks down
and gets caught in your kidneys yeah I
had ragged up almost died yeah so you're
literally like a week in the hospital is
a long [__] time yeah and if you have
those issues they don't kick you out
automatically no they Med roll you so
after I got done I uh after I got out
the hospital I went back to Buds and it
was like hey good on you for not
quitting because instructors didn't know
I was sick they thought I was faking
yeah because a lot of cats like they get
the hell weekend they don't want to quit
but they don't want to find a way out so
they'll start thinking oh I'm sick I'm
dying so they thought I was one of those
cats so when I got back to the barracks
instructors were like dude was so lucky
you didn't quit we didn't know it was
legit yeah it's like yo good on you but
hate to tell you guys start day one all
over again so I started day one all over
again went through another week I was in
with Mark Lee who's another legendary
seal um he was a first Navy SEAL killed
in Iraq damn so we were in class
together and uh went through three weeks
of first phase again got kicked the nuts
watched like another 80 90 dudes quit
started hell week but at this point you
kind of like you kind of know a little
bit yeah I knew I knew what was coming
yeah which made it slightly slightly
it's still painful you know what yeah
yeah
[Music]
I'm wrapped up in the story all right
and you guys are like pace yourself and
then you would you like shut up Gatorade
keep going keep going Remy I'm sorry
about him so I made it through hell did
you guys get pedicures during Halloween
you're the one who's like [__] there
aren't any English speakers in Nigerian
no you're awesome I won I've won this
podcast so far keep going I'm sorry I
apologize I'm sorry you asked if you
passed yourself and those Un-American
multi-colored shoes I'm gonna go into a
[__] seizure if I keep staring at him
he's ruining the story keep going a lot
bad guys
so I went and went through first phase
again made it made it through hell week
this time you know good feeling after I
made it through hell week because I have
failed my swims because I you have to do
a two mile time motion swim once a week
and I failed almost two miles in the
ocean once a week yeah and in San Diego
with great whites everywhere yeah yeah
at night time no daytime how fast do you
have to go you got it in first phase it
was 85 minutes and second phase it was
80 and then third phase is 75 minutes
it's not enough time against Curry it is
it's a kick is it cold freezing cold at
the end of every swim I was either
borderline hypothermic or hypothermic
because your wetsuits they give you a
wetsuit but that's but for me I had no
body fat I mean that was just all muscle
I had no body fat to insulate me so
um after I made it through hell week
they uh they performance rolled me uh
two classes but I so I didn't have to go
through hell week again they just waited
for the like the next two classes to
finish hell week past my finally passed
my swims and then I got the second phase
which was diaphase so I finished the
first eight weeks which is like the the
vetting process for the most part after
you get through diaphase after you get
through first phase then now they're
like all right we're gonna start
teaching you some of the principles of
becoming concealed because we know that
you've made it the biggest part yeah so
I got to die a phase and I failed my
first two swims and diaphase because the
times dropped to 80 minutes and then I
we got to dive week which is a week
where you do a bunch of different dive
tests you do like night ditching down
which is you're going to water with your
dive gear on you got to take off all
your dive gear in a certain sequence
surface to the top which is doing FSA so
you don't keep compressed air in your
lungs breathe and then swim back down to
your dive gear and put all it back on in
a certain sequence if you get one part
out of sequence you fail the whole test
so I passed that then the next day you
do night ditching down which is you do
the same thing blindfold it then the
next day you do Wednesday you do um
buddy Gear Exchange where you and your
buddy are underwater sharing dive gear
you got to take off all the dive gear
off your body put it on yourself and
then he does the same thing and then you
do that blacked out Mass nightbody Gear
Exchange so I passed those four tests
but there was a test that you do every
day which is called the tread and that's
that is the the you want to talk about
near drowning that's like the worst
tanks so two dive tanks on your back you
have a weight belt yeah I want to divest
you have on all of this gear and you got
to keep your hands above water for five
minutes and tread and it literally feels
like you're drowning [__] as soon as
your hands Touch the Water you fail
and then after you finish the five
minutes you got to swim the length of
the pool on your stomach and then on
your back on the way back and then once
you touch the wall you pass I fell the
tread four times every day when you do
uh um uh ditch and Dawn and all of those
other tests after you finish the test
then you do the tread if you failed it
then you do it again too as you fail it
then you do it and if you fail it so I
failed that four times and because I
failed that four times I failed my first
two swims in diaphase I went to an
academic review board and was like yo
listen Remy you know swimming my no your
thing you're not cut out for this you're
not cut out to be a seal and that was
the first time in my adult a life that I
took responsibility for my actions
because after I had made it through hell
week I thought I had arrived I got super
prideful I got mad probably I mean I'm
going downtown Gaslamp district partying
hooking up with girls telling them I'm a
seal and on the weekends the instructors
would show up
and they would work with anybody that
had any issues so if you if you had uh
yeah that that picture up there with the
dive gear on with the uh
second row to the left left that one
yeah so that's that's uh that's uh buddy
Gear Exchange because you got one guy
taking the dive gear off the other guy
so that's in the CT that's the same
place where I did that test all that
water [__] yeah and you got to do a lot
of that on breath holes and then you got
another test called pool comp with
instructors swim down to you and they
tie your knot your hoes in a knot spin
you around they destroy your gear
underwater and they wait for you to
Exhale so you'll be breathing on a
regulator as soon as they see you
breathe out all your in and they come
out they hit you tight and you're like
damn chicken neck and then you got to
figure it out on with no air and you got
to fix it in this in a perfect sequence
when you fail that's that's one of the
hardest tests
and so uh yeah it's gnarly from the
Bronx
so uh when I got kicked out
it was humbling but it was necessary
because like I said I was out partying
telling girls I was in the teams I
wasn't showing up on the weekend when
instructors would say hey we're here for
remediation to work with you on swims
work with you on the track work with you
on what I was too hungover for partying
because I thought I had around like yo
I'm already a seal that I didn't show up
and that's why I ended up getting kicked
out of training so I got sent back to
Camp Pendleton this time I'm with the
grunts first Marine Division
that was humbling bro like being with
the grunts Marge Ground Pounders I was
in scout sniper platoon for a little bit
and then I went to 81 Mortimer 81
millimeter mortar platoon and then thank
God a year and a half later I was able
to get back in the Seal training my lpo
who had like I said there's always been
people who've come into my life at the
right time to help give me a push so my
lpo who was like my supervisor first
Marine Division he went from that
position of becoming the command career
counselor in front of you know in charge
of every person's career that was a
corpsman in first Marine Division so he
went from being in charge of 12 dudes to
be in charge of like 1200 dudes and
because he he had worked with me he knew
my work ethic and he knew I wanted to
get back to Seal training he went to the
command he was like listen Remy wants to
go back to Seal training he's a good
dude I know the policies he has to stay
here for three years but let's hook him
up he's going to make it and so the
command master chief was like all right
he just has to sign a page 13 13 that
says if he doesn't make it he has to
come back and do three years of first
margive and then you know XYZ so I
signed that page 13 went back to buds
started day one all over again another
three weeks of first phase you wanted to
see yeah I went through hell week made
it through hell week got to freaking
diaphase made it through diaphase made
it became a frog man then you became a
seal became a sealed
bro and then how long till after you
complete all that and your official frog
man till you go on your mission yeah so
after I after you finish buds
you know I want to say this because a
lot of people can confuse just for the
audience every Navy SEAL completes buds
ain't nothing special about making it
through buds for guys with seals to at
the public is like oh yeah you made it
through points but that ain't nothing
you know all the teams do that every
seal has gone through buds every Navy
SEAL so that's just what you take you
you're not really a seal until you start
doing the work because that's you right
so you get invited into a Seal Team unit
right you're an FNG
[Music]
do you do the work up until you do a
pump all that stuff so it's a pump so a
deployment okay so so after you after
you graduate buds
you go through you go through uh sqt
which is still qualification training so
you go through you know like see your
school which they beat the brakes off
you and slap you around and you know put
you in a cage and all that stuff to
simulate at that point you're not
[__] you're not giving up on anything
no no at that point you're you have the
rating of the seal which you're rating
like your Navy rating is so which is a
special operator you just don't have to
tried it so but but this is of course
Pilots even go through Seer okay so even
pilot everybody has to go through
seriously go through sear go through
jump school which is static along static
line first you jump out the plane and
then your parachute opens right away and
then you have to go through free fall
and then after Free Fall then you go
through the rest of sqt like land
Warfare you learn all attack the actual
tactics of the scene by the time you go
on a mission you are ready oh you're
ready you're right God damn you check
into a platoon some guys get lucky and
as soon as they get to their uh command
they they meet their platoon in country
and so you meet your platoon in country
so that and then you come back and then
you do your work up cycle so work up
cycle Cycles like Pro Dev which is
professional development so whatever
your specialty is going to be or if you
already have a particular specialty if
you want to build upon that like if you
if you're a sniper and you want to go to
Advanced sniper then all the seals go to
these different schools so I was a human
guy so I was a human intelligence guy so
I went to like a few different trade
craft schools and freaking did freaking
training up here in La you know
surveillance training I went to school
learned how to run sources and all that
stuff got into intelligence got into
intelligence you were doing the [__]
that people really talking about yeah
yeah did you ever join CIA no but I but
I but
so so the DIA is a lot of people who
work with diinci is the same thing
essentially a lot of people don't know
that people hate di that's like they're
like what's that what's that both the
iaci you guys and they contract right so
that they can like see I have a contract
out to guys yeah so that's yeah a lot of
guys will do like ground ground Branch
or ERS or different stuff like that and
you get guys who'll just actually do the
Agency Route thing but for me like
because I was a CEO you know I was like
every Special Operation arm have some
type of human or I didn't know about
that you know when I was a kid I loved
James Bond and all that stuff so when I
got into the teams and I found out yo
there's a human arm and you get to do
all of these you know meet with people
run sources and wear regular clothes and
grow your beard out and go places and do
cool things like that like I was like
I'm in I'm in and a big part of why I
wanted to do it like a lot of seals
don't want to do it because it involves
a lot of writing writing yeah but you're
a writer you're a house writer yeah you
write script but yeah cause my mom would
as a kid which is a part of the story
that I forgot to touch on you know where
a lot of parents put football or
basketball in their kids hand or put
them in Jiu Jitsu or golf clubs or
whatever my mom was all about writing
God bless you she was like hey if you
can articulate your thoughts on paper
you will never be without a job you will
always have a job because everybody
needs a written word in some way yeah
and so she would make us read New York
Times articles she would make us read
books like I'm talking like thick books
and she would like write a report and we
couldn't go outside and play until the
report was perfect like I remember she
would I would write a report just to
rush because I was a little kid I'm like
789 and I want to go play she's like
nope start all over again do another one
pick another article by the way when we
talk about being a badass and being a
seal and all that stuff then you tell me
stories about your mom and I'm like yeah
yeah she might be the baddest person she
is you know she is for Real she is she's
legit and so like you know when when the
opportunity popped up you know our OIC
he was like hey who wants to go to human
School most guys are like nah cause the
last thing they want to do after doing
an opportunity with source is right and
I was like I've been writing my whole
life so that's where I really learned
like visual writing because you have to
write in a way where somebody could pick
up an intelligence report 10 years from
now and read those events happen that
day what were you where were you
deployed what countries Middle East
Middle East yeah yeah yeah I try to be
vague I
I think it's interesting like you look
at the success so many guys that come
from your background like you look at
Jocko you got Tim Kennedy you got David
Goggins there's a whole list of other
guys I'm not Matt best yeah Andy stump
yeah there's a reason like when once you
guys set your mind to something you get
outside yeah yeah you get into this
world you gotta just run it yeah man you
run it you guys have this special set of
skills yeah yeah then you're also good
you're really good you know obviously
with human behavior you're good at Team
stuff yeah team yeah the team the core
that's what you say about football like
football players I'm from my experience
I think you would agree yeah there's
social intelligence their social IQ is
high yeah yeah because they they first
of all it is diverse you're in the
locker room with all different
backgrounds but you're also like you
have to you have to rely with your team
yeah and when people do Sports they're
just individual and stuff like that
that's when you get kind of the odd bird
the weird but like I find that with Seal
Team guys I find that with football
players yeah yeah there's something
about that team spirit you know it's
also like the weakest man the biggest
issue yeah like in the CIA deals on
football teams not to compare football
to seals but it's like the weakest guys
can be your biggest issue on the field
the biggest liability Yeah by far 100
right and so you know the human thing
work worked out for me well because I
grew up in the streets so I so like I
remember going to human school and they
were teaching us all these principles
and all these theories and I was like oh
so that's what it was that's what I was
doing oh so that's so that's how I was
reading people it was like it's meant to
be it was meant to be and when I got
overseas I was I had to sort when
somebody was lying to me a source was
lying me I knew he was lying me when I
told the source to go do something and
they did it differently without them
even saying anything I knew they did it
all of that came out
there's more to it no human intention
you can tell the lines that's
interrogation you think about the bad
guy I'm talking about the sources that I
read with my friends it doesn't matter
sir yeah you're not no water but the but
you so that must be pretty cool to
immerse yourself in that culture food
and just the people you loved it I loved
it man I loved it I enjoyed it and
because I lived Best of Both Worlds I
got to build the intelligence packages
go through the intelligence read reports
write reports and then go on Ops based
off of that intelligence and so you know
I heard a lot of people even when I got
oh you got seals you're the military you
just go do aimlessly go do stuff you
don't know anything you're just doing
what the man is telling you it's like no
bro like I read didn't tell I watched I
saw the pictures I saw the videos I
dropped in on people on her yeah I met
the suicide bombers or the I know I know
it all so I wasn't we we're not just
enough no op happens like that a lot of
people think oh you could just go after
no it doesn't happen like that before
you can even go on an op the Intel has
to be vetted by multiple different
levels and multiple different means yes
you can't just a source can't just say
hey that guy's a bad guy like okay I'm
gonna go get that back it doesn't work
like that sometimes it takes months
there was a guy that we were tracking
for like four months on the deployment I
was on and dude it took months of
intelligence gathering before we could
even go out door we tried going out on a
door with him one time like early on in
deployment didn't capture him because he
had so many people in pocket he had the
entire city cops everybody pocket and
then we just kept on building building
for months you know talking to different
people agencies talking to different
sources and then finally after we had
this nice package built Source gave us
gave me a phone call came my interpreter
phone call he said yo dude's at this
spot right now what dude hasn't surfaced
in the loan yet well he's here right now
and he's here's where he's going okay
let me confirm that information based
off of other intelligence that we found
on him where he usually goes when he
when he resurfaces sometimes carry out
boom hit the target dude was right there
on the target it takes a lot of work
it's not as simple as people I heard
I've heard it's been briefed like by
certain friends who are in your kind of
thing yeah whether you're in delta or
whatever yeah and to hear about how you
guys like the ingenious method that the
military yeah if you're a terrorist
they're gonna get you now you might be
able to skate for a while yeah but if
you come up against the American yeah
military machine bro they can find you
in the craziest you would never think
right like like I was talking to a guy
who's whose thing was Isis yeah and the
way you know if you ever you know we
don't hear about Isis anymore yeah
there's a reason yeah but the way the
way like that our special ops units kind
of yeah took it's like you guys want to
fight you want to start crucifying
people and raping women and throwing
people off the roof yeah oh okay you
want to play that game yeah yeah we can
do that and the U.S military was like
hey you guys those guys yeah like there
was a news reported Brad the other day
Brad said he's like yo did you hear
about those what for Americans that were
captured and and and two of them were
killed in Nigeria I was like nah he sent
me the article I was like it's a wrap I
was like they go CAG you know yeah
it was just in the news like two what
two days ago three days ago yeah three
days when I showed you so about probably
four yeah yeah yeah so those guys are
probably taking care of it yeah yeah
they're gonna be tracked they're going
to be found and it's going to be over
they'll be fine yeah yeah yeah yeah and
you're probably not gonna get captured
probably gonna get taken out yeah and
that was what I loved about the
community it's like you're operating at
the tip of the spirit it's a whole
nother world you know sometimes a way to
describe it's like an alternate universe
how long were you in the team I was from
2000 and 2008 to 2016. damn eight years
yeah man yeah and did you use that a
long time for a seal some well some guys
do between guys do between like four and
sometimes like a guy I was with
yesterday he's he's going 30. some guys
were 35 years but you were active and
like on Mission
well by the time as you get up as you
get higher up like you're more of like
you know Admiral or like a master
commands you're you're overseeing like
but they're probably like they're not
going unless they want really really
want to but at that point you're like a
CEO or you're a messenger yeah but a lot
of guys the older guys going to other
task forces right they'll go into some
guys yeah some guys yeah yeah dude a lot
of guys once they retire but not a lot
but a good note like I know a good
number of guys who've gone to the agency
and done that so then how in the world
you go through all this and then you get
into Hollywood yeah bro so his first
movie Transformers Yeah man so which was
2016. that was when I worked on it I got
out in January 2016 I was in grad school
get my masters because you know I'm
Nigerian so my bachelor
so keep this going so I I got my balls
getting my masters and then uh I was
going to go into business Consulting my
wife's um my wife's uh uh brother is a
YPO guy I'm sure you guys over here YPO
young president's organization okay yeah
in order to be in you have to be a
millionaire and or a billionaire and
under the age of 40 degrees Yeah Yeah
Yeah you know everybody has the ability
yeah and so my brother-in-law is a YPO
so I was he was hiring me to do business
Consulting with him and his YPO group so
you know I'd take him out and take
Special Operations principles that
translate into business you know
communication leadership you know mental
toughness all that stuff and just create
these principles and watch them to these
guys yeah and I saw my bear crawls know
sometimes and then uh uh uh that's what
that's what I was going to do that's why
I was getting my Master's in business uh
specifically organizational strategy
because I wanted to not just have the
Navy SEAL thing I wanted to have the
education behind it and uh I was writing
papers in in my office one day and my
phone rang and it was this lady who
worked for Michael Bay and she was like
yo listen Bay is doing his next movie
and he's looking for somebody with your
background working real quick Michael
Bay director Transformers what's the
movie that inspired him to
what's that movie that was yeah inspired
him when he's young uh um oh Armageddon
bad boy yeah
bad boys
bad boys was his first movie oh [__]
that I was just I was just emailed with
Mike because the other day he's a he's a
he's appointed he's a good dude yeah it
was crazy 45 now I'm 40. you're 40. what
a life yeah man 40. yeah yeah and so
yeah she hit me up was like hey would
you like to work on this project and I
was like Hey that dude's movies inspired
me dude like yeah and so she said send
me some pictures I sent her some
pictures and then you know finish up my
my homework for grad school and then
next day I was up up here in L.A on set
and it was just supposed to be one day
one day turned into three weeks went to
pull out the uh Arizona four-week film
out there then flew out to Michigan for
two weeks filmed out there and then at
the end of that second week in Michigan
the casting director said hey I'd like
to keep you on for the rest of the film
so I stayed on that film until uh until
uh December I was on that film for like
six months and then that's where like
other doors started opening as a
consultant on film and TV shows and so I
did like some commercial work Consulting
on those and then I got hired to work on
other TV shows and they hired me to be a
consultant on six underground and then
that's when I started to learn a
business and learned that all the power
and the money is not in being a
consultant instead of creating that
content it's in writing the stories
coming up with the concept bringing it
together and a lot of it comes from IP
so that if I can so if I can create some
form of Ip first intellectual property
yeah yeah I.E the chameleon book you
know the transform book if I can create
something like that then now a studio is
going to have to buy the intellectual
property
and then they're also gonna have to buy
the screenplay if I write the screenplay
and then I'm going to get a producer
credit now I have longevity think of
people like you know like JK Rowling you
know what I mean where she's like she
wrote those books and now she has an
entire franchise and not just books
Empire so that was my thinking you know
so I wrote I actually wrote chameleon
first as a screenplay and then fast
forward I ended up getting a three book
deal with Harper Collins William Murrell
because they read the screenplay and it
was like this is an amazing concept this
could be a thriller series that can go
for a long period of time and so that's
kind of That's So things begin to
blossom and grow as I begin as I started
with Transformers and then started
working all this stuff started to learn
the business start to learn hey I'm I'm
more effective behind the camera because
I'm a creative I have that creative mind
I'm like an engineering mind like my dad
and I I'd like to be in the business and
that's something that's how it all came
together novelist yeah yeah biography
yeah insane yeah didn't you do something
on human trafficking yeah so I I uh
that's how I got into directing I uh um
is that the plane no we're just playing
not playing as a film that I that I
consulted on and acted in but I I
partnered with a few different human
trafficking nonprofits when I got out
when I got out I was trying to find
different ways to serve I find this with
a lot of people in the military where
they're just like dude how can I serve
how can I serve you know I know I gotta
have a job but I still feel that need to
serve and I kept on getting contact by
contacted by human trafficking
organizations like when you heard your
story like we know you weren't traffic
or anything but can you come help out
and I would always say yes and I was
contacted by this one human trafficking
company organization like around 2017
and they use seals and former Special
Operations guys and former agency guys
that go into other countries and rescue
kids trapped in sex trafficking and
these are kids who are being bought and
paid for by Americans specifically what
and uh yeah Philippines Mexico yep
Dominican Republic
yeah it's disgusting and so I was down
at Dr man and and it was crazy man and
and and when I got back from that trip I
was just like I felt helpless because
it's like yeah you can go on it Apple
you can go on and you know jump or
whatever it's called and rescue like 10
kids but they're still going to be
hundreds of thousands 200 it's a or
human trafficking is 130 billion dollar
industry worldwide 35 billion dollar
industry here in the U.S and isn't the
hardest to detect too it's one of the
hardest to detect yeah explain what it
is because I think a lot of people don't
understand so human trafficking in in a
nutshell is slavery yeah that's that's
what it is there's different facets in
human trafficking so when people hear of
human trafficking they automatically
just go to sex trafficking that's not
what it is so that's not just what it is
sex trafficking is a facet of it but you
have organ harvesting which is what my
film focuses on the short film
um the unexpected but then you also have
Labor trafficking we mean Oregon
harvesting they're taking organ
harvesting kids and people kids yes yes
yes it's a massive diet some die some
some people like for example there was a
story that came out of uh Costa Rica I
want to say about two years ago uh this
Israeli um doctor with brokering kidney
deals in Costa Rica so he would so if
somebody in Israel needed or not just
Israel but even in America needed a new
kidney and they couldn't you know get it
in time because the weightless was too
long they would contact this particular
guy he would find a match in Costa Rica
and he would essentially you know pay
them pennies and then have the person
fly out and perform the transmission
yeah and and uh you know I it's a it's
uh Cairo Egypt is considered organ
trafficking capital of the world India
has a massive organ harvesting issue
India or Indiana India India
um um Africa there's a lot a lot of
parts of Africa
when you say human trafficking so the
one part there's sex trafficking sex
trafficking yep there's Oregon organ
harvesting labor labor is another
iPhones and Tesla well the the Middle
East has you know the Middle East when
they're building those big constructions
they import a lot of people India these
very important countries the World Cup
when they build the World Cups they use
all that that's not you're living in
you're living in you're basically an
indentured servant yeah and there was a
huge problem in a lot of the Middle East
countries where Filipino Maids would
come in women they get their passport
taken yep so I just I just started to
cut you off I did a podcast last week
and uh part of the podcast was talking
about this girl this lady from um um
Philippines who a wealth not the family
were Doctors Two Doctors here in America
and they got this girl from the
Philippines brought over took her
passport took everything she worked as a
slave for years it got discovered
because the sons fiancee came to visit
the family and she noticed the signs and
symptoms of a traffic victim she was
like it's something different she's very
sheepish she's like very quiet like
something's not natural and come to find
out she essentially called The Human
Trafficking Organization they looked
into it that woman had been enslaved to
that family for years that's horror and
it was another Filipino family it was
another Filipino family
yeah that's where human beings do yeah
to their own is there another layer is
that there is also marriage so forced
marriage so that's another form of
trafficking you know we the the term is
often playfully uh mail order brides but
there is a there is a there are a lot of
girls from East Africa who essentially
get traffic to even the UK and other
parts of Europe and they're sold as as
brides that they don't want to do it
yeah I'm assuming the the guys aren't
friendly to them well every situation
yeah I was shooting a movie in Thailand
we were at you go through the soy Cowboy
the sex you know like the strip clubs
these lady boys were doing that we had a
guy that takes us through the whole
thing well I'm I we walked through these
girls were 14 years old dancing yeah 14
and 15. yeah there's and I know how old
they were yeah they were not older yeah
and you watch them dance and you're
watching these like these these Western
tourists and I'm looking at it and I and
I said to the woman I go those girls are
really young yeah and she goes they're
families they come from the north of
Thailand where there's no money their
families send them down you know yes yes
and that's how they make awesome on that
yeah and it's just the way it is and you
can get real really dark because there
are pockets of the world in those areas
where the children they know that there
are the tourists will pay a lot of money
yeah that's sex with an eight year old a
six-year-old a five-year-old yeah that's
what happens and it's so much more
prevalent than anybody realizes yes it's
horrible even in America
Africa even America you look at these
sex trafficking rings that are good
it's not the [__] so Dr speaking of Dr
what you just said when I was what
really jacked me up and hit that switch
where I was like I need to yeah when I
when I was like I need to be able I need
a bigger microphone instead of just
these I need to make a film and what
inspired the short film was when I was
in Dr I was in this particular slump
where the parents sold their daughters
to traffickers in the north because
that's where the westerners would go to
have sex with the girls the kids kids
kids right bro so I'm in this slum and
we're part of the job on this particular
trip was to educate the parents like hey
here's what's happening to your
daughters his was going here's some
resources stop selling your daughters to
these guys and so like I was just
frazzled my mind was just I was just
like yo I couldn't take it and so our
liaison saw that my my head was all over
the place and he was like Hey Remy Remy
come here I want to kind of help help
explain this to you he walked me into
this this like I only want to call it a
chapel but it was like a makeshift
Chapel that was the sign of size of two
like handicapped toilet stalls that's
how big it was there were like a few
small little pews in there and at the
end of the chapel was a dead baby in a
casket baby had to be like six months
old and so what the guy said to me he
was like the baby died because the
mother her breast milk ran out because
she wasn't getting enough food enough
enough sustenance and so she mixed the
formula with the water
and that's what killed the baby here and
he said Remy this is the plate
it's desperation for them this is why
they're selling their daughters because
in their minds it's like either we sell
our daughter and receive x amount of
money every month from the services our
daughter's providing which is pretty
much nothing anyway
um or all of our kids die and even that
didn't make it under like oh that didn't
justify it for me at all but it did help
me understand not just that form of
human tribe but all human trafficking it
all comes back to the desperation oh
there's desperation of the victim or
whether it's desperation of the of the
trafficker which doesn't justify it in
any way you know I interviewed this guy
um after like right around the time the
short film came out I interviewed this
guy who was trafficked from Venezuela to
uh Colombia from Colombia to Mexico and
he was enslaved in Mexico and and one
thing he told me he was like yo man he
was like I just I was just so desperate
to get to America and that's how they
got me so essentially with the cartel
and not just the cartel but other
traffickers what they're doing is
they're sending pamphlets out throughout
South America India like there's people
on the order like I meant from India
Africa like all around the world because
that's the Port of Entry all around the
world and so he was like this they're
creating these makeshift
pamphlets or you know emails saying hey
come here because there's leniency on
the border and we'll get you we'll get
you into the U.S that and so he that he
was like oh Roger that he paid the money
came up to got up to Mexico as soon as
he got got out of got out of the airport
they gave him like a job for a day like
a day later they wrapped him up threw
him in the back of a vehicle at gunpoint
and drove him to like a mansion on the
outskirts in that mansion in that house
there were there were rooms that were
like essentially jail cells no doorknobs
and they were guarded by armed guys and
all the people in those rooms were all
traffic victims and he said that the
women were used for sex trafficking the
kids were used as mules which is another
form of trafficking which is drug
trafficking because the kids were so
small that they were able to fit through
the tunnels to get into the U.S to move
the drugs in so the kids were used for
drugs trafficking the men were used for
a combination of Labor trafficking but
they were also used for money so
essentially what the men had to do was
they had to call up a family member in
the U.S and had the family member send
twenty thousand dollars and if that
family member said to twenty thousand
dollars then they would be allowed to
they then they would send them in if
they don't send it they kill them they
essentially kill them and he was he he
was the last guy there and he was able
to see he escaped butt naked ran across
the border he was able to get into like
a a church I think he said like a
monastery or something in Texas border
patrol came wrapped him up and that and
now he's uh he's in in Georgia trying to
seek Asylum and how I found out about
him was one of the guys in my short film
The Unexpected he's a former seal I had
a few seals that either worked on the
film behind the camera or in front of
the camera his good dude his name is
gonzo his dad is now hosting
um sorry his uncle is now hosting this
this guy and so he had equals because he
was in the film he's like he called me
away he's like yo Remy you're not gonna
believe that he's like this guy who's
traffic like he's staying with my uncle
and he has this crazy story you need to
interview him and talk to him man this
dude had the records and receipts and
everything of what happened and if you
feel guilty when you complain about
anything oh yeah man you know what I
mean it's like yeah
right yeah right correct thank you I
can't take a piss thank you sir yeah and
one thing he said I was like yo what
would be your message to American people
he was like you guys need to clean up
the Border he said because because you
because because you guys are creating
you're creating you're building a
friendly for this yeah I agree with you
said you guys are creating an atmosphere
of slavery creating a Marketplace so
many people are coming you're creating a
market for slavery commodity yeah they
get stuck on a board of traffic you're
literally creating a market where where
those really bad people do the worst
[__] to those people on the way to the
border the other thing that's alarming
is that there's a there's a you know
there's a network of people out there
yeah that are keeping that business
alive 400 in America 100 and that was
another that was another thing I wanted
to touch on on the short film The
Unexpected is how intricate and how
intelligent
these organ harvesting human trafficking
rings in general but organ harvesting
rings are you got to think about it you
know the people the majority of the
people who are involved have to be smart
why because they have to be doctors and
surgeons there was a human there was an
organ harvesting ring that was busted in
uh Cairo Egypt around 2018 and of the 45
people arrested the majority I think it
was like 30 of them were doctors or
nurses that performed the surgeries and
so all these people are very very like
they're brilliant organized crime
organized crime to the team yeah there's
so much money yep and to what you said
earlier you said it's not as detected
that's right it's it's much more you
know think about what I did when I was
like all right I'm not gonna sell drugs
in the Bronx because it's too easy to
get captured and and it's too too much
competition so I'm gonna go through
Poughkeepsie these guys know why sell
drugs when I can sell a body human body
making way more money and human beings
when economies are bad yeah and that's
the case human beings find amazing ways
to survive yeah yeah and you know that's
what people always say like the economy
first yeah like you got to build those
economies up one of the things they said
about stopping the border is make those
economies places people want to live but
as long as you have things like what
happened to your father which is most
the country most the world without
property rights and things like that
that's why corruption though of course
make all these other countries better so
it's better for you guys of course yes
but I'm saying I'm saying that's why but
that's what I always say things like
democracy representative government
property rights contracts rule of
[__] law our institutions have to
have integrity the FBI Etc it's so
important that's that's why corruption
is so bad yeah and and that that's why
our country Remains the greatest country
in the world because you can depend on
it yeah you can depend on it that's why
I get so angry when people start talking
about Civil War and civil Strife like
shut up shut up yeah and also social
media is not real no it's not that's
crazy the rights crazy you can fight on
there yeah it's like oh man we're in a
race
I think you know I think I like you know
and there's been there's been evidence
of this I think that there's you know
other countries you know and especially
specifically countries who run us
particular you know um social media
platform called Tick Tock you know and
it's proven that certain content they
they will push up that content via the
algorithm so that it goes to specific
they want to show Strife
but that was Russia and China's plan
China's been on this for 50 years yeah
yeah they're like we're not going to be
able to go in there and beat them
physically kill them from within kill
them from within right get them to fight
amongst each other then they're
distracted yeah I can't get off Tick
Tock I mean I don't have it on my phone
but I was my daughter was like no I see
them I see him on it all yeah
but I feel like I've eaten a bunch of
candy after there's always something to
watch even yeah I've never seen a tick
tock I've never I don't know do you have
an addictive personality don't go on it
yeah but not towards that stuff I don't
I've never been addicted but you can
find like stuff that's actually just
cool sound bites political stuff you can
find now there's only places to get it
if someone held a gun to my head and was
like give me your log on login for tick
tock yeah you'd have to I yeah I don't
even have it tick tock no I don't know I
told him I was like yo bro I ain't
messing with because even with the way
that they're pulling information the
Chinese are pulling information from
everybody's Tick Tock account correct
where you are even if you're not well I
got one so you'd probably know this with
Intel yeah one of the things that uh
everybody has a tick tock profile so if
you have you if you want to go deep
undercover as an operative okay yeah as
a kid you were on Tick Tock they got
facial recognition technology now watch
this now you're an Intel guy yeah maybe
I'm saying too much but you're an adult
and you got to go to a you got to go to
a country let's say an African country
let's say a poor country yeah yeah okay
now you got to walk you got to
infiltrate streets you got to do your
work there who do you think is building
basically for free all of their traffic
uh cameras yeah all of their
infrastructure from Chinese yeah who do
you think now has all your all your
metrics your Facebook metrics now you're
there and they just go they do your
Biometrics they go he's he's a foreign
National they look at your passport they
will even if you they look at that
another reason not to pick it up you
know Montana banned Tick Tock first yeah
yeah yeah yeah I don't know why Morris
don't do it that's what happened because
there's a thousand different things like
that because consumers go [__] off I
want to use this but more importantly
that's the Insidious nature that's where
China has all your facial data and now
that and and they're building all the
sort of camera traffic infrastructure in
these African countries I was about to
go next they're taking all of the
freaking resources out of Nigeria yeah
and they're creating this Trail I I
forgot the term but it's this trail of
that they're creating from Africa that's
going to run some actual resources all
of the trails they want the trailer run
roads yeah yeah and so so so we're gonna
literally have absolutely no access to
resources in the next 60s so smart and
here we are you know fighting about dumb
[__] amongst each other you know that
that doesn't really hold any weight
where you know what what are we're gonna
have to I'm worried for my kids man to
be honest with you and this was all by
Design what's going on that's all yeah
actually the U.S if you look at it China
has a lot more problems in the US uh we
are still there was just an article
about this we are still so far and away
ahead of everybody else economically
innovatively technologically that you
know that there is a tendency to worry
about that but China let's start with
China's demographics they don't have a
population that can support their
rapidly Asian population thanks to their
one child policy for 30 years the
problem is our codependency on them like
he said 50 years not so much anymore
because so much the chips act so much
the infrastructure is coming home so
much manufacturing is coming home not
really yeah
no no no there's a huge there's a huge
the chips past first of all we're gonna
start making all our microchips we're
taking it out of Taiwan we're making it
back here but manufacturing is coming
back here you've got 3D printing you've
got AI all of that is originating here
yeah most importantly China doesn't have
access to fuel to natural gas
but they're trying yeah but but but you
know remember that's an open commodity
on the market so it goes to higher
better highest bidder you've got Europe
India's buying it India's buying it from
Russia and then selling it not to China
they're selling it but China relies
heavily on us we rely heavily on China
that there's I know it's getting better
which isn't bad as long as China plays
Fair yeah promise they they have one man
in charge it's the cult of personality
with G the problem was they're so
ingrained with them they can play how
they want it yeah yeah and we're you
know
yeah we're we're so caught up in our own
foolishness that you know we can't even
you know read the tea leaves to figure
out how to move strategically to get us
where we need to be well you need a
leader of the country to focus on 100.
yeah I recommend Remy yeah
man I think the way I try to do it is
through culture through sharing my story
through you know um telling other
stories to trying you know even in the
chameleon book I made it a great effort
to make it not just an Espionage action
thriller but to make it a political
thriller to just wake people up in
politics because we're just so divided
yes and you know a lot of decisions in
politics are not made for the greater
good of the people we the people is made
to keep one side isolated and keep
trying to build on that one side opposed
to everybody and so I really addressed
that in the book I can you know I kind
of put the pill in the donut so to speak
because you know it's just one of those
things where we have to come together as
a nation you know black white whatever
transgender gay straight whatever we
have to come together as a nation for
the greater good and we have this a lot
of it is prior to lot of people just
like me and mine you know my team and
it's like not even even in politics you
know somebody on the left does something
wrong right like nobody on the right
wants to say hey that was good somebody
on the right does something right nobody
on the left one second that was good it
has to be bad and and if somebody on the
right does something bad nobody on the
right wants to call him out somebody on
the left or something nobody wants to
call out and it's just we've created
this tribal one of the wisest thing I
heard Jordan Peterson recently says you
Liberals are here to argue for what
needs to be changed conservatives are
here to argue for what needs to stay the
same yeah yeah and the reason you need
political dialogue is to figure out what
changes and what stays yeah yeah and
it's a beautiful way of looking at how
this country was founded of course you
need liberals and conservatives you need
to be able to disagree yes but you also
have to have them talk to each other
conversation of course conversations
have to you know understanding leads to
Unity yeah you know people fear what
they don't understand once they begin to
understand but you can't have
understanding unless you have a
conversation you've got to have a
conversation which will lead to the
understanding and understanding of lead
to the unity you seem like a realization
I take credit for that dude
you guys ever take days off maybe seals
when you're tired [__] dude I'm so sorry
I'm sorry I asked that question
what's up so the ball comes out July
25th um that's the advanced reader copy
for you guys beautiful Australian
um
um you know it's up for pre-order now
this is around transformed transformed
is that's my Memoir that's been out
since 2019
um so that's out now people can get away
our books are so I did the audio read
for both books and uh yeah man love it
man I can't thank you enough for coming
in hey thank you for having me on
brother I appreciate it come through uh
La Jolla comic cup I will I will I'm
gonna bring my wife yep my wife because
we gotta go on a date before I leave uh
leave the country in June anyways we
appreciate you brother thank you so much
appreciate you guys great